[Music]
two
hello my friends welcome and thank you
for being here on this beautiful august
first day
in the lord's year of 2022. what does it
mean when people say the lord year is
that like a specific thing or can you
say that about any year
every year is the lord's year ever i
mean every day is the lord's day
that's right okay so it's the lord's
year guys congratulations for being here
uh to say that is a year after the birth
of christ any year after the birth of
christ i believe any year isn't there is
there only one year after the birth of
christ
that would be like one right
i don't know that's just okay all right
let me let me get clear interesting
interesting okay
guys today our episode is sponsored by
hellofresh
take a look oh my god are you kidding me
look at that
look at that oh my god
i would pay i would pay easily
would you pay for that i'd pay i'd pay
like 18 bucks for that
i paid 700 for that 700 you're not being
serious
i pay a lot for that though right now
listen this is just one of delicious
meals
that we've tried through hellofresh
with one
with over 50 manual market items to
choose from each week you'll never run
out of dishes to try
get 16 free meals plus three
gifts with code h3tv 16 at
hellofresh.com
h3tv16 thank you hellofresh we love you
so much
cooper troopers love hello fresh
the official
i'm not going to say it's not really but
the official sponsor of uh
foot soldiers
okay
the official monster is a wiki feat
um
huge shout out right now at the top of
the show to my new best friend
dave portnoy who dropped the claim
he removed the block the dmca has been
recanted
and uh i'm now bffs with the bff podcast
yep
and dave is my favorite guy may i call
you dave
davey david pork boy pork noy it's going
to be hard to shake that i'll be honest
but not only that this is the week of um
mending fences as they say this
wednesday
is our big bonanza with tana
mike
and jeff
that's exciting this is this is gonna be
interesting
this is gonna be an interesting
experience this wednesday right here in
the studio no less wow
it's all happening
it's all happening actually let me see
uh jeff sent me a dm about
yeah yeah
still working out the time i'll believe
it when i see it man when those three
walk in the studio i'm still skeptical
yeah i'm so worried they're gonna
reschedule i'm going out of town next
week and i really want to be here for it
so i hope yeah
no i believe in them those are my these
guys would never steer me wrong they're
good they're good people the three of
them really good people
um also i always want to give a quick
shout out you know this is the best
shirt this shirt is so nice it's so
classy do you know what it is
um is it your elon mustard nope oh
oh thatcher
i sure it's sold out dude that's what i
heard
yeah
this is actually our basics line
teddyfresh.com here it is
classic pigment dye pocket teeth this
shirt is so nice you guys it's like a
perfect shirt
it's classy it feels good the branding
is on point and you there's a pocket it
means you can put stuff in it check it
out look at all these beautiful colors
too
um
wow
a pocket
and this this is cutting edge stuff
what's the capacity on that bucket uh
it's rated for about uh
two pounds two pounds yeah that's solid
wow
that's solid yeah i think so yeah
you know but yeah wow
wow
there it is that's just one highlight
wow
of the classic pigment dyed t-shirt
there's actually a whole collection of
them they're zip up hoodies
these their shorts these oh
classic pigment dye and so much more
teddy fresh.com thank you
all right
oh yeah dan duh
you what what happened you look so
different what'd you do you got rid of
your beard or something even beard
purged why'd you do it
[Music]
i don't really know i was shaving like i
normally do yesterday and
sometimes you just get like sometimes
you just want to start fresh a hundred
percent you know
you know i have this really weird thing
lately i get like eczema under my facial
hair and it's so [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and it gets all
nasty or it gets like nasty it just
peels a lot
and it's like i can't really ever
address it unless i shave all my hair
off i don't know what's going on with me
guys i started like just having eczema
like a couple months ago i never had it
my whole life
wellbutrin didn't you just start the
well butcher in a few months that could
occur to me too i just can't i can't
deal with that anymore i can't if it's
about you chin i just
i don't even want to know because i'm
sweating i've got eczema it's just like
it's not it's just not working out
i like the wellbutrin so i just i'm
burying my head a little bit here
yeah also there's this weird thing i
can't hear my left ear yeah i don't want
to find out about it
i'm just kidding this is a funny joke
about butchering side effects oh
thank you
yeah but you look good people are saying
you look great dan people are saying you
look young smooth
shout out to uh dan i'm hearing people
say you're the shave king
they're saying you're naked well don't
get used to it because my beard grows
really fast and it'll probably be back
and by the end of the week
yeah when you shave off your beard do
you have like dry skin or you got no
problem did you use a razor or a
beard trimmer i just used a beard
trimmer yeah at the lowest setting so it
wasn't like a true a true shave right
all the way down right
okay well shout out dan and also abs got
a fresh cut
just to just to acknowledge everybody
a little eminem style yeah little eminem
represented detroit are you going to
freestyle for us not today
next time
what happened you just bleached it yeah
i don't know i just got sick of like the
half and half it looked sort of like a
boy band to me so
i always just try to grow up my natural
hair but i end up just bleaching it
and did lena do it
i usually tell people to do it but
usually it's just me
you didn't help him lena
no he didn't need help this time
sometimes i just do like a few of the
back pieces to make sure he got it all
covered but not this time
interesting i would want some oversight
if i was bleaching my head
yeah i think i wanted to ask her she was
streaming at the time so i just did it
myself oh my god lina you're streaming
yes and yeah you
so so this is so are you is there some
conflict now you're there you're
bleaching your hair by yourself lena's
streaming it is it is difficult because
like i wanted to like change my clothes
i don't want to get bleach on it but
she's streaming and she's front of the
closet so i have to like crawl to get
like an extra pair of shorts and no
whole ordeal yeah
i'm growing my hair back people oh lord
lina's turned into a gamer girl right in
front of uh i wonder what andrew tate
would have to say about that yeah i'm
waiting for us to get evicted from our
apartment because she's so
loud i mean it's funny and god bless her
but
i can only imagine what the neighbors
are thinking
we're looking for new places now yeah oh
you are we actually are yeah
[Laughter]
well good luck wish you guys the best
thank you
zach dude i'm not showing this you know
guys we talked about zach's ingrown
toenail i'm not i can't show this [ __ ]
bro it's
dude maybe i can show it can i show that
i mean it's as graphic as last time i
guess no but this time there's like
blood and [ __ ] there was blood last time
i mean dry blood it's like a huge shard
of nail it's like a shark tooth yeah
it's like a shark tooth what the hell
yeah so the homie my homie podiatrist
the og hooked it up and
got that [ __ ] right out he had to numb
me and um
did he have any commentary about that
other podiatrist did you tell him about
your experience he knew of him okay and
he's like that that old [ __ ] still
working no he didn't say that
he'd be honest he said that he's like he
needs to retire oh my god talk about
professional courtesy he must really
[ __ ] hate him yeah usually doctors
don't [ __ ] talk each other i told him my
experience what happened and he couldn't
believe it his jaw was dropped
um yeah because he didn't really do
anything for you and then you're your
boy
um he made it worse
to be honest with you oh my god so i uh
it wouldn't have been so invasive this
time
if i just waited to go see my my main
dude
um i really want to show this but i
don't know what do you guys think is
this too graphic
uh let me i mean let me take a look here
it's really bloody
yeah dude it was [ __ ] gnar he numbed
me up how's your how's your toe feel you
feeling better it feels better it's
still a little tender um a little tender
yeah but um i have it wrapped right now
but he hooked it up jesus man does your
other family members have this ingrown
toenail problem or yes yeah my mom my
brother my dad
that's what was embedded in your toes
yeah yeah [ __ ] up dude i think it's
probably okay to show to be honest
because it's so like abstract what
you're even looking like it wasn't what
i expected it to be right really
it just like it's pretty early i'm
photoshopping a pg version
okay this is for scientific evidence
only my wait what are you doing kim
you're doing i'm photoshopping a pg
version getting rid of the blood right
now if you want to oh good i like the pg
version
thank you photoshop obviously guys if
you're
well cameras making it pg this is like
you know that safe for work porn where
they like they like draw a frame like
really vulgar porn and they're like
playing the
macarena or something
so that's cameron right now for us
okay oh this is great this is great
yeah so this one's actually not even
really
that vulgar but uh fair warning i'm
pulling it up right now damn grand
square what's up dude thanks cam
yo
[Music]
that looks crazy yeah dude
and then well in the original pick
this whole side here was covered in
blood right and then in the original
album i have my toe which is not
graphic
um oh yeah after
but yeah dude that [ __ ] was in there i
didn't feel a thing because he numbed me
did you were you watching or were you
just laying down i was watching it the
worst part was getting the [ __ ]
needle in there
so this was all removed yeah dude and
then the the ingrown thing was like
under your skin it was going into the
right side of my toe
it was like just buried in there and
you watched him fish it out with
tweezers no what he does is he takes
like
i guess for a lack of a better term
nippers
and just um nippers yeah like no like
you know and just cuts it out and um
you mean like a plier for your toe he
doesn't like pull it but he cuts it it's
like it's like someone offered to buy it
zach would you sell that i unfortunately
don't have it oh what a god he missed a
great opportunity i know but i he saved
my life my podiatrist because i couldn't
walk and it was just awful and i was in
pain all the time so but wait what did
he do what's a nipper so like toenail
cutters oh
nail clippers and just [ __ ] went
really deep because i didn't feel
anything i was numbed up
and just cut the side of my toenail and
just got it down to the root and just oh
wow
cut it right out whoa
mama yeah so
so glad i don't have this yeah it's
you're lucky it's because it's a [ __ ]
there's got to be a better solution
though can't you just rip your toenail
off or something and just call it a day
there's got to be a better way to i mean
maybe amputate it um what's this acid
treatment i've heard about so what what
it is is it kills the root do that of
the toenail i think if it keeps
persisting the problem is
um
i've been instructed how to cut my
toenails properly and i cut my toenails
and a few days later this happens
so
it's just i'm gonna have to go to him
once a month to have my toenails cut
love is really insistent i've heard him
talking about this quite a bit you've
got to become annoying you gotta fix it
with the acid love to give you have
insight on this acid treatment
i used to watch this dude i saw a couple
people he shot before said there's this
dude called toe bro shouts out dude
he's on youtube primarily but i've seen
it a little bit on tick tock
just [ __ ]
like opens the toe a little bit sticks
in like a one of those ear
things with yeah with some acid on it
that's a fetish photo if i've ever seen
no he he has ready to lick that soul he
he posts some gnarly [ __ ] on there yeah
he hooks
you up though he's a podiatrist yeah toe
bro toe bro his thumbnails are wild it's
gnarly i want it's way more graphic
happy to be doing that he definitely
wants to look your feet him and see man
dude
he hooks you up though dude he saves
people out here so anyways my podiatrist
where's toe bro wait hold on where's toe
bro located can we send zach there says
canada oh [ __ ]
i wasn't gonna send you to toe bro zach
i'd love that but he's in canada um but
yeah i uh i'm definitely feeling better
and um
he's gonna lick his toes
funny
by the way um
what the [ __ ] is this camera just sent
me this
it's just just pg versions of things oh
yeah yeah yeah some pg versions okay i
see i see yeah what are we gonna do
about it
um by the way did you ever send that
ninja foot pick to c-man
uh
yeah i did actually i have not heard
back from him if i recall
c-man has about
25 emails or like every time i ever talk
with him it was like a different email
address
he's a little hard to pin down so i sent
it to the one i most recently
communicated with him on but um see man
we're looking for you dude nothing we
have important matters to discuss
some of his other uh and some of the
other contacts that i have
we got to throw a bat signal of the foot
up in the sky and hopefully he sees it
he'll come running
anyway glad you're feeling better zach
thank you
uh there's a lot to talk about today
okay so
first of all kind of an interesting
thing to unpack here oh well we're doing
the elderlies at long last
my dad meets jimmy lee
i don't even know man i don't know how
this is going to go
it was pretty wide i actually do know i
was going to go terribly yeah
you know you think it's going to make
them both look do you think my dad looks
really bad
there's
i mean we talked about it there there's
a moment that
dad my dad kind of failed the test your
dad was trying to match jimmy's energy
he can't really fault him for
[Music]
i just my dad is kind of like um very
progressive socially
but i realized just the chasm that
exists between
the new generation and the old
generation
you just can't fix those they're old
school
boy aren't you right
it's going to be a whole experience
though i tell you that
well also we have the the whole unedited
uh
one and a half hours for members is that
right
a little over that yeah oh my god two
hour podcast well a little less than two
of jimmy lee and gary klein all up for
members i don't know who will want to
watch that yeah shout out to members
that's our second uh long-form members
content this week we just put up a
30-minute behind the scenes right now so
there you have it
good job baby good job everybody
members
eat your heart out two-hour podcast
is that a benefit or a punishment
i well they don't have to watch it you
know what i mean
but
to those that choose we do we do salute
you
and then also uh andrew tate was on the
elk boys and i always like [ __ ] on
him so that's good there's a few
comments he made in there they're just
absolutely next level
it's a vibe right now it is a vibe
you smoke a dart but i wanted to do
something you know you guys heard that
somebody in illinois won the the 1.3
billion lottery
yeah
yeah i'm sorry kim i know who's to say i
didn't catch a red eye you know
i went to chicago i went up to chicago
yeah my good friend out in chicago
you know well maybe the real
lottery jackpot is the friends we made
along the way here you know
it was the 1.3
i'm just hoping
um well shout out to that guy but i'm
always fascinated by how much you
actually get
so they say the jackpot is 1.3 billion
and we try to crunch the numbers here uh
to how much this guy's actually gonna
get you know
the jackpot number is pretty deceptive
because it's based on taking monthly
payments over like 30 years or something
or is it 20 years i believe it's 30.
yeah so they're like
they they're like it's worth this much
based on if you like put it in a
investment portfolio and
and over 30 years it's like well no [ __ ]
dude
so most people should just take a lump
sum which so if you do that it's worth
750 million
clearly not bad
not complaining about that but it's like
half
and then the irs
takes the 37
daddy
thank you
the irs gotta love that lottery man they
win every time that's right
yep they're stealing it they're stealing
it
oh yeah they love that [ __ ]
um
so the irs gets 275 million
and still we and still teachers got to
spend their own money on pencils
what are we doing
is this covert related what are we going
to do about it
and then illinois state tax which
luckily for him is only five percent
here in california it's 10
represent
illinois gets 37 million
five percent means everything
in this case it's only 37. it doesn't
seem that bad joe
the final take home from 1.3 billion
is
and again i'm not complaining this is a
lot of money
433 million dollars
are you complaining no no probably is it
1.3 billion
honestly that's so much money it's
430 million dollars that's cash right on
the table boom
no strings attached anymore 430 billion
that's so much money yep
that's got to ruin their life right
yeah i mean there's lots of stories
about lottery winners having tragic
things happen to them after the fact or
they blow it all wind up anchor up super
quick how do you spend 430 mil well i
guess most lottery winners don't win
that yeah dude
and thankfully in illinois apparently uh
the winner is able to stay anonymous not
the case in many states um which is part
of what leads to
a lot of trouble for a lot of lottery
winners
they're like dang jeff what's going on
here you just uh
rebuild it you bought every house on the
block and you're building a 50 000
square foot house interesting i wonder
where he got the money
well anyway shout out to uh the the dude
in illinois
who should have been making money today
i was robbed yeah i'm sorry i know you
really wanted it next time who wants me
to take their money i used to win the
lottery every other week when i worked
there so
it sounds a little sauce cam
well i mean
through my salary at the lottery
oh they used to pay you yeah they use
the payment yeah i don't know i don't
did they pay you in scratch off no i
wasn't even allowed to play for the
longest time until only recently that
expired so this was your big coming out
of the this was the first time i bought
something oh
yeah it was a special thing for cam he
thought he was going to win
next time though it would be a nice
story right like i couldn't play for
years this was my first time playing
it would have been a good story next
time
next time there's always next time for
sure
you know
how he's going lost his mind on tick
tock too which is pretty interesting ow
i think he's been emboldened by the
the prolapse he's really
he's really going in like look at this
one he just posted
mute it because it's got music but
dude how he's a menace to society he's
just going in ice cream shops and
pouring vanilla on his dome i'm growing
my hair back people
is this not a germaphobe thing or maybe
the ice cream doesn't bother him
it's sterile
the ice cream's sterile sterile yeah you
think that's all good howie you're a
menace man
i love this man what do we do about the
menace to society what's next you're
going to go to the chipotle and put us
he's going to put a scoop of guacamole
on his head i don't know if that's
sterile but
he's out of control
he's growing his hair back people this
this this
this prolapse has been a total disaster
for howie's mental health
i mean what else is on here
it's all just bananas look at this
it's amazing
you should see the view from my couch
it's amazing
[Laughter]
not good that's kind of mid show the one
with the it's a good sound center
when he posted the what that that was uh
a deep fake of an old commercial this i
don't get yeah this is an old commercial
with a really bad deep fake
it barely looks like him
i didn't have used though 13 million
views
jesus
yeah i got it
it's just it doesn't even look like him
oh it's supposed to be howie that's
supposed to be howie oh
you just see what i'm saying
um
but
i thought there was more weird stuff
i'll be honest
what is this
my friend neil
howie you okay bud
oh my god howie he's having a good time
he's living life oh he's got nice legs
actually absolutely i'm not even gonna
lie
i'm just you know just lick your lips
after you said that hmm
get a piece of that
yeah i'm keeping an eye on you howie
we'll never forget
you know what i mean all of his top
comments since that video yeah on this
uh
on the ice cream one the top comment is
is this covert related if so what do we
do about it on all of his videos the
last one too it said we'll never forget
no we will never forget howie you can't
just move on he
goes he's trying to distract us no you
we will never forget what you did and
i'll be honest howie
i recently did bobby lee's podcast was
choosing out yet
and i did hot ones snacked or not hot
ones but the uh first we feast snacked
last week which isn't out yet and both
of them when they gave me a chance to
plug something i said howie mandel
tick-tock
go watch the prolapse anus tik-tok i
swear to god i said we cannot forget
spreading the gospel we must not forget
that this happened and i told everyone
go look at this that was my that was my
plug
that's awesome
howie
this is part of your legacy now when my
friend neil bent over
this is my legacy
what do we do about it what do we do
about it
what do we do about it
[Music]
what do we do about it
my friend neil
ow bent over
my friend neil my friend neil
and this happened
we will never forget
what do we do about it every time i have
something to plug i'm gonna do how is
prolapse tick-tock
guaranteed
from ever forever
i'll be 60 years old working on
something completely
unrelated i'll write a book or something
and i'll be doing a show trying to
promote myself
does somebody know is this covid related
and i'll say
howie mandel prolapse tick-tock 2022
ow look it up
why is it when i type my name there's
all this unrelated [ __ ]
i wanted to show you guys kind of what
like
i found ways of acknowledging it without
being vulgar like this neil bent over
this happened
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what do we do about it
so we have to be creative too
more immortalize it so if you guys have
anything that's like safe work that
looks like a prolapse let me know did
you see the slushy one
no oh
what i want that oh
is this the one where they squeeze it
and it freezes no no no no no okay i
want that give me a minute yeah give it
here i'll post it right now
ow
[Laughter]
i want to post it right now
i like that concept though that it just
becomes sort of like
it can become more and more abstract and
you'll still like recognize the the
format of how in the corner
prolapse in the winner that's it that's
all i want
you know
actually as you find that olivia i have
another story to tell
so my dad went to a dodger game with my
sister i don't know is it too late to
divorce my family can i file still to
separate
or is it kind of pointless at this at
this stage in my life
my dad and sister went to a dodger game
my sister did this
i thought she was i thought she was
normal
and she went to a dodger game
with my dad and it turns out she's
[ __ ] up too oh
wow sister snapped wow like realize that
was your sister that did it this this is
how and i know this might seem extreme
but this is how nazism works right this
is how it took hold in germany right you
just you believe that this is normal by
association
and it's not normal you know you came
for the beach balls
go on
and i said no finish the analogy
i'm just saying this is how nazis take
over the world
i mean shame on you to my sister why why
would you stoop to this level sister
snatched
sister snatch yes so the story is sister
snatched
my dad i saw my dad overlooking he's
like i'm so proud of jessica
he goes
the beach balls were flying
jessica got a hold of it she didn't stab
it this time
but you can see she opened the air lid
and then squeezed it out
everyone was booing her four people were
shouting at her like what's the matter
you don't like fun which is you know
right
and she was like yelling at them and
apparently flipping people off oh boy oh
boy
i just don't know who these people are i
i don't i don't want to be associated
with this
this is [ __ ]
psychopath i mean how is she
guys help me here what what am i going
to do about this is this culvert related
sister snapped
i don't know you just have to live and
let live here i'm not going to dodge
your game without obviously not
convincing your father or or your sister
but after all the outreach i did on my
dad yeah my sister's now out there doing
it
that's what you get for for platforming
uh vicious beach ball
poppers smash so you thought you could
engage
and that you could turn some minds but
look at this it's spreading this is why
you can't this is why you can't platform
people like gary klein
he's like a he's like a baseball
war crime
needs to be sentenced
okay so we found the slushie olivia okay
let's see what is this
when my friend oh interesting someone oh
someone is carrying the torch what is
this leo bent over this happened
does somebody know is this covid related
okay i'd like to see it go i like to see
it noland
oh it's just one post this guy
he had his moment
shout out nolan
the slushy pro my friend neal bent over
loved that keep it going guys come on
so that's it i don't know
my family's just a perpetual
disappointment to me i'll be honest
someone just pointed out hitler actually
killed his first beach ball at age seven
so wow that is really messed up that's a
sign that's scary well at least my
sister's like 50 she's old as [ __ ] yeah
so not till she's like a hundo
she won't kill people
yeah okay
can we have a h3 fan meet up with dodger
game where we fill the entire section
with
people doing the wave and throwing beach
balls non-stop with gary sitting in the
middle bro it's called explosion therapy
that is such a funny idea it's really
fun it cost a fortune though i guess you
could get a bunch of nosebleeds for like
20 bucks
yeah dude that would be so funny
get like 100 seats
what's 100 times 20 that's not bad it's
like 2 thousand bucks
well i mean i bet people wanna just
come along like you wouldn't necessarily
have to foot the bill that sounds like i
just wanna make sure that they're all
troopers there if we could buy like a
whole grid oh i see
i feel like if you buy far enough in
advance and just tell people like hey
get this section you know oh my god that
would be so freaking funny can you
imagine there's a 100 b12 is being
launched at my dad at dodger stadium
oh two speed very good idea
very very funny
but okay enough about that let's move on
to
what everybody's waiting for speaking of
my dad
so i'm not ready i'm not sure i know i'm
ready for this the elderly's
so the back story here of course is that
everyone had this bright idea
with jimmy lee being you know the
character he is we says let's see what
happens when my dad meets jimmy lee
now how long did we film for you and it
was like must have been like three hours
right
uh yeah around there yeah something like
that
so we had games prepared for them
quizzes tests
and a surprise call which will shock you
that's in this edit right
cam yeah okay
um oh boy
i've fallen
and i can't get up
i'm nervous to show this guys i'll be
honest
so they came this is a 10 minute edit of
the three hours like i said the two full
two hour unabridged version director's
cut
is on for members
or will be to be clear or will be okay
and so i don't know what was the
experience like for you guys because at
one moment i had to step up to do the
first week feast i was there in the
beginning and end you guys want to put
some context to this
i
somebody else is probably
listen i
i have to come clean
[Laughter]
jimmy lee
is my kryptonite man i i i can't
i can't with that man i really can't and
i mean i know he knows that because
every time he sees me he's like oh this
guy hates me doesn't he and i have to be
like no
but it's not really so much hate jimmy
as much as like i can't be in the same
room as you for longer than like two
minutes like
you're just
you're just a singularity of cringe for
me like and and i
i how about high tolerance for cringe
but i don't know it's just something
about jimmy it's just really
it was it was nice meeting it's brutal
it was brutal it was oh yeah his kids
were there yeah it was nice meeting
these kids were really nice very
no he's an enigma i don't know
i uh i don't i it's gotta all be them
the mother
as far as she must be
he says she's a saiyan everybody's
present and i and i absolutely believe
it and
again it's not it's not that i hate the
man i i do think he has a good heart but
it's just the the
just
giga level of unawareness that he
possesses is just it's cryptic to me
like i just can't well we gotta cam and
i have to deal with it when we go home
because he texts us still yeah uh 30
times a day the same [ __ ] picture
that we've seen a million times yeah he
was trying to get my phone number i said
absolutely not you will never get my
phone number jimmy and he just he spams
us and it's just getting to a point
where it's
it's very frustrating no i mean i don't
mind talking to him when he's
out of character as much but you know he
does he does send a lot to us he's
always on though i just ignore a lot of
i mean when he when he was when the
cameras were off and he was over here
talking to his family he was a nice he
was a nice very nice yeah personally i
like him but i like it yeah it is a lot
i had to walk away and i have to commend
ian for really like taking charge with
the segment because i
a few of us
just kind of deal with it i don't think
maybe keep leaving in different uh at
different times
my my problem with jimmy at this point
is that
we invested a lot in this whole
redemption arc for jimmy people said it
couldn't be done
and yet should have listened
and that yet we did we did we tried and
there was a moment where he was redeemed
it did seem that way
and we were all on board with the jimmy
train and then he posts this video on
instagram like that and a bunch of other
stuff and he goes
this was kind of the
a big factor in this video where he says
i can i say the m word is that i can say
it in context of this right what of the
little people slur oh the m word yeah
i'm just saying i could say that right
he goes
he says man i hate midgets
he has this whole bit
and we're like jimmy you can't say that
word you have to say little people and
also just don't look it's just a weird
thing bro like
i hate mages man
well the other thing is i think he's
adapted a little bit of an ego now right
he's big time right uh so
it's a lot
on top of his histrionic uh
personality disorder as he would say
so anyway um
we tried to confront him on that and
like the whole thing was like dude
there's certain brands of comedy you
just have to stop doing and you know
everyone thought i said n word no no no
no no no no no no back it up
i was that m
[Music]
yes so um you all thought i was about to
drop that n-bomb huh
well i just misheard you
after we barely survived the weekend if
you guys know what i mean yeah
i didn't even want to say anymore yeah
let's move on but if you know you know
i'm just happy to be here guys
everyone heard the n word
thank you carlos
sound okay got it
identify that i can i know it's carlos
just from that one like oh no
and you know the problem is that we
really thought we were making progress
and then he just busts down the door
with like just super offensive stuff and
it's like jimmy i just don't know
i don't know if we can do it
dude he walked in uh
making a uh uncomfortable joke what did
he say uh it was towards lena right evie
wait what what did you say lena lina
what did he tell you i forget he asked
if i'm arab then i said yes and he put
his hands up like that oh yeah he goes
don't shoot he goes that's a classic
don't shoot and then he does that to any
minority and then he says he said
something about sam too what are you
doing
oh
he just asked if i'd ever heard of the
sun yeah oh yeah that's all that's all
classic jimmy
because i'm pale i don't know
there's not turning them off
were you offended by that lena
no i i yeah it was expected
yeah you expect
kind of expect that harassment when
jimmy's around
but that's kind of a that's a funny bit
because he literally says that to any
minority it's like bro think about what
you're actually saying every minority is
a criminal
hey don't rob me what are you mexican
hey
don't shoot
and then his thing is a son's [ __ ] it's
sons [ __ ] i hate middies man and sons
of [ __ ] sons of [ __ ] sons [ __ ]
[ __ ] i think he was making progress
after we talked to him yes and then he
started on cameo and started to get more
people who probably were encouraging him
to make distasteful jokes about their
friends and he was like oh people love
this [ __ ] i'm going back to don rickles
the the the off the rails he called in
the first time in the restaurant it was
gold that was fantastic he wasn't
offending anything so funny it was it
was great and then it just kind of went
downhill from there i think you're onto
something ab and also he's getting lots
of dms with people like tell me a joke
yeah and they get posted to subreddit
right
so i don't know but you guys tell me
we'll have to take a pull
let's do a poll right now and then after
the segment
so do you like jimmy lee yes or no
right just simple
and my poor dad man i hope he i hope he
got out of this okay i thought my dad
for the most part he was fine it was all
all jimmy okay and it's just again there
there is
a moment
and unfortunately it might be the worst
moment it was bad i remember it was bad
it was so bad do you like jimmy lee yes
no i i think your dad looked at it more
of like he was a guest here and he was
hosting him and was trying to make him
feel comfortable at different points
well i'll be honest we hit him with a uh
i don't know if it's a gotcha but it was
what did i do
that wasn't me i don't know they said
don't spoil it oh oh
i'm giving context
they're right though like
it's better if it just happens i'm
devoting yes even though you know
it's very split we're at 50 about 50 50.
okay so there you go the majority are
saying yes so jimmy that's pretty good
51 saying yes i mean that's that's
powerful stuff
okay
powerful stuff so let's watch this
and then we'll do a pull afterwards and
see if it if it moved any minds here i
guess let me end the poll because
i don't want people voting during this
yeah yeah no no no we want to keep this
pure all right guys without further ado
it's the elderly starring jimmy lee the
jersey outlaw and gary klein here we go
hey jimmy lee very nice to meet you gary
klein i am ethan's father great to meet
you very nice to meet you we're gonna
have to you know go in to do the hair
makeup get the hairline right the makeup
right a little powder little paint makes
me what i ain't okay how about you
joining in and doing it with me that'd
be great i don't need help with the
hairline but the rest of the stuff
definitely uh i could use so let's let's
do it okay let's go the viewing garage
in about two hours for both of us
no pain no dirt on you tuesday burning
me wednesday i i actually did some
research on you because i i couldn't
actually believe you were a dentist and
it's not going to come as a surprise to
you but you are actually a dentist i
wasn't aware i was practicing i was
aware i had histrionic personality
disorder
i was a dentist first of
what histrionic personality disorder is
i could probably make a good guess uh
you tend to be histrionic all the time
gary you look marvelous it looks just
like you well thank you i
feel at least six months younger now
three al two
one jimmy do you not know the numbers
three two one there we go one two three
no
olivia
i knew not to let you do my hairline
i'm about to lose all my gray i want
gary non-gray for this episode
olivia no no lower well i'm going to
hold it is it even right now
that's it
oh
thank you
it's pretty good
so hold on
[Music]
[Laughter]
look like i have something on my head
i'm not sure what it
is welcome everybody to the elderlies
starring gary cline and jimmy lee the
jersey outlaw
two of the great comedic minds
uh comedy titans meet together at last
to get you guys acquainted we have
arranged a little game pull one card and
it's going to explain
make an assumption about me
i assume
you're a dentist
i assume you're uh
someone with a great hairline i assume
you
got a cool la shirt
just to wear out here for the trip
correct
and uh i assume you're going to have a
great time out here in los angeles well
that's a matter of opinion my wife's
so pleasant
think of something
that you dislike that most people love
zach's personality beach balls at a
baseball game
yes so now i want you guys to create a
secret handshake together one
two
three
and then four and that's just jimmy and
gary's handshake there is
a house in new orleans
they call
the rising sun taking care of business
and working overtime zach workout get
that guitar zack
under the laptop in front of gary are
instructions on how to open the show
document hey colb
go get my readers i'll help gary i can't
see
my readers
and i can't get out that's adobe guys
[Music]
hey
all right now what do we do by the way
how how long did it take them to get
logged in i think it was like
cam do you was it like 10 minutes
uh hold on yeah i mean all they had to
do was the both of them together had to
log into a gmail account and open a dock
yeah which which is great because my dad
was specifically making fun of my mom
when she couldn't you know do that test
true
and there was the two of them
my dad goes when i saw him the week he
goes dude it's like you know i just i'm
not used to the chrome books you know it
really threw me off i was like oh please
i just love how they ended up on adobe
on the adobe website somehow
yeah
anyway
so far so good right uh yeah it's going
great what could possibly go wrong so
far so good everyone's having a good
time
here we go let's go back i love you i
love you you like my hairline zach it's
fantastic jimmy it's receding like my
jokes hey i'll say to you i hope you
jump on your bike and there's no seat
and that could hurt a mother
no danny's not going to hurt his mother
just take a viagra and chill
okay
gary today you finally found the rabbi
and you said i'll join him and you went
and became a jew
wonderful to me
jimmy i got to ask so you said that your
issue with people these days is that
they're a little too sensitive is that
what you said
yes we've prepared a little something
listen you're shrinking did you take
preparation h i hate [ __ ] midgets man
i don't want anybody sniffing around my
fly unless they're serious
[Music]
i need to confront you on something okay
i know which one it was which one i
don't like midgets ethanol
oh get me i just never liked them
the word midgets is very offensive okay
we don't use that word anymore i thought
it was a pretty good joke jolly roger
liked it pretty funny
it's just an old style joke that's
really what it was what'd you think of
that gary
all right so
we're basically we planned the
intervention for the for the whole
[ __ ] thing
and i was expecting my dad you know to
kind of
ride for the social issue he thought
that was a highlight reel
he's clapping so
just praise yourself guys go easy on my
dad please
some classic offensive humor i i think
it's very clever and very smart because
if you're going to go after a new
learning group who is less apt to hurt
you than midgets or little people right
you make
other groups they have big
serious threatening people not midgets
what are they going to do come up and
kick you in the knee or something that's
uh okay i'm really glad you said that
gary because
we actually okay so
clearly he
failed
he failed the test
but actually the worst part is guys
uh what comes next and boy just notice
their fa i mean
and in the role of a lifetime gary all
right i'm just gonna play it everybody
tighten your sphincter
actually have a little person
on the call they've been listening
and so dan is gonna bring them in right
now and we can sort of open a dialogue
here
[Laughter]
so
this is aubry
so far so good
gary
gary
gary hello aubrey hi gary how you doing
how you doing good love you
well thank you even though you think i
would come up and kick you in the sheds
well i have pretty low shins too so and
you guys are both pretty short so i
wouldn't i would really become an
outdoor community
yeah so this is uh aubry
a comedian
who
wrote to us
uh a few weeks ago they were posted on
the subreddit actually uh so he posted
on the subreddit yeah oh yeah right
right and he was saying that you know
he could talk to us about this whole
jimmy lee [ __ ] arc
right little people arc
and so we had planned this call in
and the setup was just really
really rough man
uh but here it goes let's see if if in
either of them are going to learn
anything let's see
shout out aubrey by the way out
oh yeah here's the post maybe many of
you may have seen it it says ethan
i'm an actor with dwarfism i'm currently
making a documentary comedy series
special about a disability hate group on
youtube that's been cyber bowling me for
over a year named jimmy lee
right just kidding i would love to call
in tomorrow during the tippy toes
segment and chat about jimmy's oh right
the post was actually about the tip
right which then as you guys know we we
knew we had this jimmy thing planned and
so it ended up working out for that he
said i want to chat about jimmy's little
people phobia and do some dwarfism
representation so we we knew we wanted
to get him on the show this is him
legend
and uh
this is this is what we did and i'm so
sorry
to him of course
well let's see does he break through
let's see um jimmy the
comments that you made you weren't
really serious like you're not actually
you don't actually dislike little people
right this is a an act it's exactly
exactly and i'm a loving
big hearted nice guy that does a comedy
act and i don't mean anything i say no
it's just intended to lay out for
ourselves aubry that's how it is
no yeah i love how jeff i love about
jimmy's thing as always we got to laugh
at ourselves it's like you know
who's ourselves
you're consistently slamming other
people only
i've been performing since in the
entertainment industry in the circus
since i was four now i do stand-up
comedy i trust me i was not offended and
i think i could tell it wasn't really a
serious comment to me no
do you actually know any people with
dwarfism i have patience okay who are
little people and i didn't do that joke
on them aubry in the office by the way
because i'm a dentist in the office not
the comedian you do come from a very
different generation where there was
very different representations obviously
of little people even medically speaking
doctors used to still use the word
[ __ ] even though there is no such
thing as a [ __ ] we are people with
dwarfism and there's hundreds attached
to dwarfism so my only question was just
if you do know little people and you're
not really scared of them but do you see
how maybe that would have like real
world implications for a group that has
no representation
is ever shown in a sexual or violent
manner like so i'm saying even just as a
comedian i really just don't think
that's the lane you want to go down okay
do you see how it's nothing about if i
find it offensive i understand i don't
think you're that person but as someone
who's literally making a movie right now
about how youtube allows people to
follow us around who sometimes are
minors and go around calling us all of
these name but that aren't even names
that are reflective of a medical
condition literally just a slur like i
just figure that you are someone who
doesn't actually hate little people i
don't hate anybody and uh zach's been
telling me to quit for years i may have
to take his advice
i don't think you should quit but i
definitely think you should realize that
comedy can be sustained without
literally using someone else as a
punching bag okay what do you feel you
can be honest jimmy no i have plenty of
other jokes i don't have to use the
[ __ ] joke everyone can be joked about
i just think it's the offhandedness and
the fact that you're just quick to move
on to another joke where i get followed
in stores and i have someone online
literally who's been stalking and
threatening and harassing me just
because i have dwarfism he calls it
[ __ ] wednesday and i just don't think
you would want to be associated with no
i don't i'm gonna let that one go jimmy
this is an iconic conversation then you
realize well i'm not ever gonna do a
little people joke again we're gonna
knock that off the dock we're letting it
go after listening to you can you look
at me without your sunglasses and give
that to me in the camera
we're swearing off little people jokes
oh we even got the term right
i have a zillion other jokes i can take
the little people jokes out we
appreciate you know you your perspective
aubrey it's been very informative and
enlightening and i hope it's resonating
like i love talking and arguing it's if
i ever came across a certain way please
don't think you are not offensive in the
way that you talk about little people
that i hear every single day so it's not
about being offended at all
intended i just do comedy i love it and
again i'm a comedian guys you don't know
my humor too so you don't know i could
be just as i could make fun of a jew i'm
right here just don't shoot me
we don't even have two jews
and planting a fire two jews walk into a
bar there's lots of other content out
there and that's what i would just like
to say as my friend well thank you thank
you thank you
please look up dear advertise people.com
making a documentary comedy festival
about that disability hate group because
youtube just doesn't care enough to
protect small creators so it's dear
averageheightpeople.com and we're
raising money right now to finish the
film jimmy you would love this it's a
comedy special jimmy we're making fun of
ourselves we're making fun of everybody
the point is to bridge the gap between
people like you and people like me i
want to say one thing mean guy are going
to say together
we
love
you
yeah what he said thank you guys thank
you it was great
thank you take care
good luck
that went better than i thought i mean
jimmy basically well i think
okay there was a lot of
finessing you actually finessed that to
making it look like jimmy learned a
valuable lesson yeah
it was a bumpy conversation i'll tell
you what yeah i mean there's a lot back
and forth i had to cut a lot for the
sake of brevity but it'll be in the
final
cut there but that was nice but
ultimately in the end actually there was
some progress with uh jimmy there
swearing off little people jokes even
using the correct term there
you go
you gotta see his reaction at the end
though after they all right here we go
let's see beard purged why'd you do it
oh that's not what i wanted
well you too guys okay bye-bye
okay
oh
now i think i need to take my metamucil
the joker you need to take your
metamucil am i allowed to use the toilet
before we go to our next segment sure
yes i may throw up
oh don't yeah then definitely go in the
bathroom
oh it's stressful for poor old jimmy
you're gonna [ __ ] and pew
i guess you did a pretty you did a
generous job of cutting that together
there kim
so i don't know
the final cut has the full context and
everything so damn grant secretary
what's up dude yeah that was some
excellent editing i must say cam it was
interesting shout out to cameron who
basically the conversation did the
impossible yeah
thank you all right well let's do a poll
then and see uh i think i think i was
expecting worse i think maybe uh
this didn't hurt
uh oh this was jimmy two days ago oh no
no he did this two days ago
wait wait wait wait wait
this so we put we had he had this
conversation
last week so this was a few days after
the intervention
and he posted i hate them midgets
jimmy what the [ __ ]
we almost had another redemption arc
i hate them midgets man
oh [ __ ]
all right well just give you guys
context he has not learned his lesson
so let's do it in one poll i guess here
and after the poll we actually have
audrey on the call to do a little bit of
a debriefing
no we don't
what
what no we don't
what
we don't have
you just pulled that out of thin air
what are you talking about
what are you talking about i thought we
had set up that he was going to call in
and we just talked about it like a
billion times we talked about it right
before the show and we said that we
didn't have that set up but we could
have him call in some time to
apologize to him yes
didn't we everyone please speak up don't
make me seem like i'm the only one yes
yeah yeah yeah
yeah you mentioned that you wanted to
set it up and then when we talked about
the whole plan was to have audrey at the
end of the bet we only decided we were
showing this like
30 minutes 15 minutes before the show
today
okay
no audrey
i was free okay whatever we'll talk
about it later
i mean we could see if we can get him on
on the call but wait what do you want
what are you guys agreeing to we it was
from the origin from the beginning yeah
but we were supposed to call him we
didn't initially plan on showing it
today today was not the day to do this
we we moved it up
because cam finished ahead of schedule
so you guys had him set up to call in on
another day
whenever it was going to happen is when
we were going to have him calling i well
you guys okay i think you pitched it
like it was ready to go
whatever shout out audrey everybody
what's the website it's aubrey aubry
sorry aubry
website is
what is it is uh it's been linked in the
chat but it's uh dear
averageheightpeople.com
or
there's also an indiegogo
project if you google it we'll drop the
link in the description yeah
our mods are spamming it right now there
you go shot
interestingly only a two-point swing for
jimmy so he this man is untouchable
you know can't be stopped he only lost
two points for that so i guess jimmy's
still in the running there go watch the
members version and then tell me if you
still like
well it still ends at the same place but
it takes a lot longer to get there
people are saying i'm getting old dude
i think it's the opposite i think you're
working so hard you have so much going
on you still got that young this was the
second this is the segment we planned is
that he will call in at the end of it
yeah why you guys all acting like i'm
crazy you're not crazy but again we
the the segment was not planned for
today's episode okay
it's humanity like it was ready to go
okay well there was no like oh audrey
aubry can't call in
anyway what can we do what can we do
about it is this culvert related
what do we do about it well i wanted to
give him a chance to
to uh you know debrief with this we
could see if there were to thank him try
and get them on right now idm so i sent
him an email
let me know
well anyway uh
jimmy's at 50 50. he has not lost oh
they're watching now so we'll send them
a zoom link here i'll send you the link
right now
it's in our whatsapp chat if you want to
pass that along
um
meanwhile
there it is
i guess
audrey
aubry aubry apparently that's drake's
name i learned yep that is correct aubry
aubry drake graham
got that middle name swag yeah
like that
shout out aubry
[Applause]
so we're getting aubrey on the phone
doing the impossible according to dan
dude
men they're doing impossible things we
are we're doing impossible things
so what else i guess we're just waiting
for aubry we got andrew oh arab world
news huge update from arab world news
let's go
huge conflict there arab world news
actually
came out
guns blazing against us
it was a little confusing i'm i'm not
completely sure
where he stands to be honest he roasted
me
yeah
yeah but arab world news if you guys
don't remember from the last episode of
uh leftovers
we discovered our new
newsman i mean this guy basically
you guys will recognize him here let's
see let's see what stories are in the
news i think this is going to have
copyright in it
i just want to get his commentary here
it is okay so this little dirk
lollapalooza incident video
let's see the debrief here
hello everyone welcome to my channel
again we have a breaking news now about
robert little dark hidden eye with bio
technique
on stage
in chicago he will take a break
after biotechnic
incident
he might need the
eye
surgery after the incident this story is
trending now on social media after a
video circulating
on internet robert the dark share a
photo of his eyes covered by
a large patch and
he will focus on his
health
in the ending of the video please
support me by like and comment thank you
for watching and support
well there you have it um
huge you know he's got a really good
format i think he's got this great
format words show the clip
and then describe it to me yeah and it's
really a powerful uh i really like it um
it's very good
and you got you got all these hits oh
here's his response to h3 podcast which
by the way
he was shout out dude he's a this man is
a cat he's a
he is a grinder he's on that grind set
he put his response behind a paywall at
first
you had to be a member to watch it smart
yeah and i like all the variety on this
channel you know and there's news but
also there's like these cute like cat
videos that loop oh is that right yeah i
saw one in discord
oh this one cute kitten funny video cute
cat okay let's go play
okay we love that what an interesting
variety and here if i just groups loops
yeah that's what i like about it because
you're expecting the cat to walk a
little further he doesn't he doesn't i
mean
he draws you in and you're like come on
just make one more oh i'm here one more
step
but it's so cute you want to keep seeing
it you know it's part of the artistic
vision yeah i just keep rooting them on
yeah yeah so we just we discovered this
channel by accident
last thursday with hassan has actually
hassan sent us a link right which was
apparently the only re-upload
that he could find on the internet and
then his face popped up afterwards like
yo who the [ __ ] is this and he said but
wait let's i want to know more
so we plugged them we gave him a huge
plug lots of love and uh
he he had a response that uh
i don't know it's almost like he he
wants to go to war with us but i i can
never
i love him
here's the response that was first
behind the paywall
and then i guess he he made it public
because he's a generous king
like
in this video i want to send a message
to my new subscriber who supporting me
truly thanks and love you all forever
many people asking me for responding to
podcast guys after made fun of me in the
last show what shall i do nothing but i
have to
i just it's like the subs there we
we did that right we did that
he keeps saying we made fun of him
though i don't remember making him
we'd love him
dude yeah we love him very much this is
the new walter cronkite in fact i wonder
if we can offer him a permanent job on
the show where he calls in every week
and does the headlines for us there you
go monday morning news i mean that would
be fire whatever
that's it because we've got a call in on
fridays
you know what i mean true do we know
which country
uh he lives in we have we made contact
with him
no i have not no i think his about on
youtube says he's from egypt okay
so we shouldn't have any problems
connecting with him there no
dude we got to reach out to him i really
want to give him a weekly segment
because i missed the news we used to do
the news it's really important to keep
people up to date but here here this is
when he lights me up
tell them you can't democrat me again
because i have a new family lovely
family surrounding me and floating me
love and support and
give me a hope to continue
thank you thank you yeah
tell him please clap please clap
uh is he making fun of me because i have
to ask people to clap for me
yeah okay
damn he skewered me
please clap he actually did some
research where do you pull these clips
from like what the hell this was the
next episode so
but and then this one
was this from the same app because
he pulled it from two different thank
you thank you yes
tell him please clap please clap
please clap don't shy ask me anything
what is up people of the world
[Music]
people of the world are watching now
russian ukraine war and going to third
war
so what can you do in this time
i think nothing you can't find anybody
to mock him
i suggest
mocking arab character or make a deal
with elon musk to send to you
uh
does anyone
well uh i thought he was saying mosque
and then i realized he's saying elon
musk
elon musk is going to send you
somewhere okay wait let me let me back
it up and try to find anybody to mock
him
i suggest
mocking arab characters
[Music]
i thought he was saying there's some
character named war he wanted me to oh i
see i don't know this time
i think nothing you can't find anybody
to mock him
i suggest
mocking arab
make
character
deal with elo mask to send to you
space you can find beautiful aliens and
the mocking them anytime they have a
smart loving beautiful smart listen
right
oh man
oh now he's coming for hassan so watch
the [ __ ] out
hassan has it coming man
be patient
or go to home and they took off your
clothes not on air please you have a
girl watching you right here
man that's disgusting we have to clip
that and send it to hassan because he's
right yeah it's disgusting
he's gotta have a girl watching he needs
to be he needs to be more considerate
i wonder guy
how are you eating gums and speaking at
same time
are you serious
actually you know what he roasted us so
good
gum i mean it's insane i don't usually
chew gum but i saw hassan with the gum i
was chewing into the mic i mean boom
roasted i'm [ __ ] destroyed from that
i mean he really got me
[ __ ]
i'm not gonna chew gum anymore after
that ross
andy paywald
this is the true sigma grind set right
here yeah he's making money off of
roasting you guys dude come on
i was ready to pay for it but i think he
he he went down the wall
i was gonna pay for it bro
you are visiting
space and they met alien and they teach
it
okay in the end of the video don't
forget support me by like and comment
for more stories
that's a shout out to arab world news
you know
it's all love he actually left a comment
someone people were trying to explain to
him that we weren't making fun of him
and then he actually had a nice response
they said us issue fans love you
neither us or ethan would ever make fun
of your peace and love right and he says
thanks dear i found out recently after
publishing my video and i really liked
them do you think i should delete this
video out of respect for them no don't
delete it keep it up man it's good
content yeah there's good roasts and
honestly valid points
i mean the gum thing
dude right on the nose what can you say
so
basically
nancy pelosi caught pushing child with
elbow i mean let's get one more update
from him that sounds pretty damning
let's see this is his latest video
no this is an older one okay oh it is
yeah what twenty thousand views what the
fridge yeah these are major numbers
okay wait hello everyone welcome in my
channel again we have a new story about
nancy bluesy appears to show uh mayor
flora's daughter at ceremony so what
happened for more information about his
story still awesome here's the clip by
the way
oh she did shove her
i haven't seen that wait when i seen
that
he's bringing you the
cutting edge yeah what the [ __ ] i
haven't seen this
look she's standing in front of our arm
right yeah
and she actually does shove her away
what the [ __ ]
dude you got caught out by arab world
news what
this really happened
i mean that that didn't look doctored to
me
can i just say i mentioned before than
the arabic language there's not a sound
there's not a the letter p that's why we
replace it with b
republican uh congresswoman to get here
shot during swearing and ceremony after
mayra flores and
elbowing hair girl and said no child
should be pushed
aside
speaker of the house nancy bluesy
appeared is the video at all
quality setting on youtube no no
[Laughter]
to someone off camera when she
went to flora's daughter standing next
to her and
this is this is incredible analysis we
got to get him on the show i'm not happy
until we get arab world news a dedicated
segment so it's all good
it's all love
and uh i'm just happy to
i'm gonna leave a uh comment on his
latest video you're gonna leave your
email or something yeah okay good
please clap see you yeah and uh make
contact here
basically i'm not gonna be happy until
we we bring back the news segment with
him at the head i don't know what's the
time difference maybe we can't do it
live but he could i think it has to be
live he's in the time the same time zone
as me i think
okay there you go so you guys can yeah
work together right now it's 11 30 in
egypt 11 30 at night yeah okay maybe we
can get him at the top of the show
before it gets yeah you know
um i do want to point out as well he has
amazing titles this is one of my
favorite right here about jim carrey
i don't know if you want to show that
video
it's jim carrey 2022
is jim carrey dead did jim carrey passed
away
good question
did he answer the question
he did he did and i was concerned
because i really like jim carrey
everyone welcome in my channel again
we'll come back with a breaking news
about jim carrey
some news have been circulating about
jim carrey this
so what happened is that true for more
information about this story stay with
us and support me by like and comment
rumors suggest jim curry is did in 2022
have been circulating on social media
however
this is completely false okay there it
is he's alive thank god
we love him
all right well we have aubry on the
phone we do
uh thank you so that we'll just say hi
to aubrey
thank him for his time
and uh
i'm bringing that man right now honor
him
for going into a pit of
vipers right
hey
oh hello is this live already it sure is
i we'll go live
you know
hi aubry well first of all
thank you so much for uh
taking on the gl uh the the uh
unt
unfathomable task of trying to
give sensitivity training to jimmy lee
and my dad
no of course it's honestly
anytime that people are willing to have
a conversation
it's so important to have a conversation
and i'm honestly like
shocked that you guys you know allowed
that to happen in the first place
because
you know just like dwarfism
representation it's just really really
hard to not be taken as a joke
um and i was really excited that the
reddit you know community and my fellow
foot soldiers were there yeah
wanting to have that conversation and me
and my producer was just scrolling
through the comments and i was i mean
there's almost like 200 comments on that
thread of me just going back and forth
with people asking questions people were
like oh i know a person with dwarfism
that i really miss that i grew up with
oh i you know
love what you're doing because i don't
like how people with dwarfism
represented on screen
um so what with the jimmy and gary think
i'm like this is trust me in comparison
to actual like people on the internet
who hate me right now and they're like
actively doing everything they can to
exploit people with dwarfism this was
like
the easiest thing okay wow but what what
was actually the most interesting is
that uh you actually seem to break
through to jimmy lee
although well that's questionable
because
two days later he did write i [ __ ]
hate midgets in his description and
apologies for using that word just to uh
to to re retell his what he wrote in the
full version i even i got caught
slipping too i was like [ __ ] this
midge of that because it it's not i want
to move past the word as the most
interesting things that people with
dwarfism can offer you know and that was
what i was ultimately trying to get
across to jimmy i was like
this word buddy and he even made a joke
he was like oh i have a few jokes
because i was like let's go through some
jokes we can workshop it and he was like
oh you're
something black and you can't i bet you
won't be playing basketball and i'm like
there's literally
people with dwarfism who they're not no
playing with lebron james but they're
traveling around the world being paid
thousands of dollars every week to be
the global uh globetrotters his name's
manny he's an incredible incredible
person and i know that in those moments
i was like with jimmy i was like we're
gonna get to the bottom of this because
he's not
manny's not sweating his ass off people
aren't sweating their ass off the door
some dwarfism on broadway
musicians teachers in law
doctors nurses they're not doing all
this work for us to just be like hahaha
midgets
now that's what my movie is about
basically it's just about like
highlighting that in a new fun way
that's like entertaining to watch let me
ask you this you mentioned that there's
people that like stalk you like you said
that you know
jimmy i mean even literally today like
earlier today i went to this they have a
youtube channel that's been running for
years that is monetized
what
what's the name should i can i ask the
name of it or do you rather not say i
i would love trust me nothing i would
love better because all it's going to
take is just more than me and 10 other
people i know reporting his account
because youtube's reporting system does
not work yeah it's just about
it's just about quantity
quantity but he's literally using i used
to post videos on youtube as like a way
of showing what it's like to be a dwarf
like what a day in the life of a little
person comedy videos in that sense right
not taking anything seriously and he
would play these videos as a part of
[ __ ] wednesdays with his thousands of
followers and all he does is literally
just say oh if we don't fetishize you
we're just going to start getting rid of
people like you yeah
literally called me the n-word two days
ago on youtube and they're making money
but no well i would rather if truly even
is i would love if you could like assist
because
i just need someone at youtube who i can
send
the links
the you know all the backup accounts all
of that stuff that i've had to compile
over the series i've never said anything
to this person and i would love for
someone at youtube a person to just be
like oh click click click
but it will be justified because you
can't it's literally i can yeah i mean i
can i can write an email intro
and then you can just explain kind of
whatever you want to say
in terms of that
i i just kind of got over that wait is
his name is the guy is the channel's
name uh keemstar or drum alert
he's he you're gonna laugh when you say
i'll i'll send him to you you're gonna
let cuz i call him
yeah i'll i'll set you up an email i am
best friends with susan of course so he
has no problem here
no problem
like little people does youtube
absolutely like a little bit just
kidding
but you said he harasses you in real
life and stuff like that no no so but
people
have
in this journey i found videos of him
reacting to other people who have
uploaded videos of me in public
and he's reacting to it because he just
scours anything on youtube that has the
word dwarf little person or [ __ ] in it
and i've literally been watching him
react to a video of me and my producer
filming a movie about disability
awareness and about the hyper you know
fixation on dwarfism and he's literally
proven my points for the points of this
film that there is an issue here because
in him harassing a dwarf he is reacting
to someone else harassing me
so
yes it's been kind but that's what this
whole movie's about it's like the
inception of that like just imagine for
a second how wild that is and i just
wanted to turn that into something that
like everyone can relate to everyone can
get something positive out of because
it's been a tough two years for
everybody you know so so the website
again is dear normal size p or what is
it
sorry i don't know i just wanna maybe
you better say it
dear ethan no
you're ethan.com
oh
um
no it's dear
averageheightpeople.com we are in the
last weeks of our fundraiser um we just
really i was shooting some early this
year and i'm sure you know like it's
just expensive you know oh yeah
definitely
and i'm at a point where i'm an actor
and i've been at studios auditioning for
stuff and
other little people as well and
there's no studio is going to take a
risk on people
right now
so considering the community and people
actually seem like the viewers want it i
was like let's fundraise let's see what
we can do
um and again you are the real g for
having a person with dwarfism on h3
that's like
well you're the real g and thank you for
kind of coming on and i apologize for
jimmy and my dad but honestly you handed
it well and you broke through to them so
shout out to your dad the [ __ ] out i
love your dad i was there through the
whole frenemies
thank you you're very gracious i'm
wearing the teddy bear i noticed that
you look great
i love that shirt by the way too
that's one of my favorites
this one was made for for people with
dwarfism so i think this was coming you
have a lot of people with dwarfism on
your side ethan okay shout out dude
out to the dwarfism yeah
love that
you guys are like
yeah people are sometimes the people in
this community are really nice and and
uh i love that you know sometimes but
but yeah like on the subreddit like you
pointed out i mean the post had 3 000
points and everyone's just super nice
and supportive and that's nice that's a
beautiful thing but um
aubry i'm going to put the link to your
website in the description
um
i want to thank you so much for calling
in and being a total uh sweetheart
and uh representative do you have any
questions about dwarfism real quick
uh i'm just simply
i'm just so surprised like why i just so
surprised to hear that
like who's walking around hating dwarfs
that's just psychotic it's just crazy
like what
i don't even understand the root of that
you know what i mean as someone too with
dwarfism like i i struggle and i think
that's why i'm
okay with it because i'm like what like
legs like what part of the bottom of the
barrel do you have to be in your life to
like really think it would be funny to
follow someone around just doing
something normal
and then film them
like
what and then say
derogatory things on top of it upload it
to accounts dedicated just to stuff like
that it's crazy man it's giving bottom
shelf so yeah yeah yeah well onwards and
upwards representation's gonna help this
guys representation will help this all
right thank you buddy aubry
legend
thank you so much
thanks for calling all right you take
care thanks aubrey god bless you thank
you aubry
thank you legend
by the way uh jimmy go back to jimmy
leepole 20 000 votes are in the man is
untouchable
53 percent yes jimmy
actually
one point up you gained a point since
the beginning so
jimmy is loving this at home i'm sure
has he texted you yet zach
uh no he's not okay interesting must be
in surgery
[Laughter]
he actually might be in the air right
now
well good job what small update um
love uh managed to secure arab news
network's email address so i have
oh
introduce myself and uh this is a paid
gig by the way we hope to hear back soon
yes this is a paid gig
for an experienced newsman
that's great i feel like you i should
have reached out just because of uh my
name oh you guys have uh you guys can
swag out with the whole the whole arab
thing yeah thing
we'll see we'll see though you want to
you want to you want to ride him well
we'll see how he responds oh it's too
late yeah swerve love he's like [ __ ]
this guy loves i mean
it's it's technically a russian name not
yeah not yeah jewish so mine is i don't
know if that matters to him
minus yeah yeah yeah well we're well we
don't know what this guy you know i
don't know anything about his place but
we're talking we're strategizing who
would be the best one to reach out i
kind of agree it would be yeah
yeah well you have love in your name so
that's helpful i guess
oh yeah and he said he was about love
right exactly
so that's exciting um
and thank you guys to the crew by the
way you guys all did great with the very
sensitive material there and
thank you dan for getting audrey on the
call
yeah sorry for the
miscommunication about that no no no he
was watching so he did it you got him on
the call
we made it happen
god bless you
all right let's move on to andrew tate
andrew taint the human trafficker
has he dropped the whole cobra thing i
guess i don't know when i realized that
how cringe that was when i first heard
about him it was cobra yeah it was
always cobra but now everyone talks to
him about like andrew i don't think
anyone's trying to sign up for cobra's
life coach you shed the cobra skin right
right right your girl but he's your girl
he still has the massive cobra tattoo
though on his arm so that may interfere
with yeah that rebrand
yeah that's gonna be hard
um i'm just i'm kind of just perplexed
by this whole cobra tape the human
trafficker phenomenon because
when we first talked about him
with brittany broski
i don't feel that he had reached
well it was starting to that was the
beginning of him exploding on tick tock
and that's why is i think you saw one of
his tick tocks right
or yeah yeah yeah or she did yeah he had
a tick tock that went viral for like
right him being a complete psycho like
women can't
men can cheat as much as they want right
women however
they cannot cheat it's cheating
whatever some dumb [ __ ] like that
um
okay but so now boys who again you guys
know about nalc they're
rip a dart
i'm gonna send it not the best i'm sure
it was just pure platforming right did
anyone watch it
just pure
lovingly olivia a b were speed watching
it before the show what was the vibe ten
minutes before the vote any contra it
wasn't like controvers uh con
confrontational yeah no not from what i
saw not at all now
i'm gonna go rip a dart
and all the comments too are all so
positive yeah yes yikes man
that's scary he's a bit older who hasn't
had too much that's not a surprise i
mean it's not the audiences it's just
crazy to me like so the other crazy
thing about this is that
all these guys flew out to croatia to
interview him
so strange which is interesting guys
because you know i want to just point
out something
andrew tate who was recently charged for
human trafficking
well i don't think he's been charged yet
he was arrested he was arrested
what's so interesting about that is that
like if you were of international felon
you could not fly to the united states
you know why because you would be
arrested at the airport
and one of the citizens who allegedly
human trafficked was an american
it's kind of interesting that he's
unable to fly to america for this big
podcast opportunity huh
i'm just spitting facts you know
there's i think there's a good chance
this [ __ ]
cannot enter the united states right now
and then the other weird thing is that
he lives in romania and then they did
this in croatia there's another thing i
don't understand
yeah that i don't i don't really know
what that's about here they are
describing
oh you sent me a time stamp but i don't
think it yeah it works it works oh it's
just at the beginning yeah okay
all right boys welcome to a [ __ ] big
full sentence by the way i saw kyle
at the posting he's super short just
saying manlet status bro
just saying
that's all i'll say
is that a problem
shout out short kings i mean maybe right
after getting off the call about being
more sensitive no no he's not a dwarf
bro but i'm just being a short is not
being a dwarf dan it's like two
different [ __ ] shoes i know right
just like so this never happens again
you know it's hard to not so when i so
you're saying you're saying kyle's a
little person i'm not saying that i'm
just saying ridiculing him for his
height
maybe just i'm done
dan you're the one that taught me manlet
i never even heard that phrase until you
told me it
like i never heard that [ __ ]
all right i mean i think that is true so
boys did i miss the sun everyone's gone
now i gotta stop you're right you're
right though i gotta stop with the l
with the short king uh slander
listen like we said we described it
there's short kings and there's manlets
there's two it's different energy yeah
yes yes no i know i know
and i agree with that
there's a funny observation though i
give you it's just
yeah my mind i give you that it's funny
it is funny it's just coming off it is
funny anyway here's kyle
the manlet
[Laughter]
cast episode we just flew all the way to
croatia
we [ __ ] hopped on a plane we're in
croatia we got andrew tate right here
lighting up a cigar guy loves guards
it's a good sign that's good
did you we need to shorthand that
how do how did all these people find you
scars
gonna spit a dart in a gar
he sounds like a pirate a dart and a car
[ __ ]
full pirate
um oh god they even made merch high mail
merge drop bro you can't be serious
high-value mail
you would have to be literally inside
yeah wear this
what would you think olivia if you saw a
guy wearing this shirt high-value mail
that is scary they're so clear it'd be
ridiculous that is so embarrassing how
much does this shirt cost
um 35.
it's a simple print that's how much we
charge for our simple printed tees but
that's just one color i mean that's
that's really basic
i just think it's iron you're wearing a
shirt about how high value you are and
it's like a 35 dollar
graph yeah not that there's something
wrong with that but you're the one
declaring that you're should be a nicer
sure yeah yeah
it's like self-affirmations right bro i
can't believe they're selling this this
is the worst thing this is so
embarrassing
[Laughter]
i can't i'm just blown away
yeah i know yeah 21 21 savage is
basically like my spirit animal and [ __ ]
i just can't believe all these frat boys
found each other these are like
this is like toxic masculinity distilled
into the into a pure potion of [ __ ]
ugly t-shirts
yes high-value men yeah i i honestly
think they're doing us a favor because
that's kind of like a walking red flag
so when you see someone with that
t-shirt just steer clear yeah
yeah yeah they're tagging themselves
yeah they away from me
i'm looking everywhere for
gar being used as a uh slang sorry bro
look i even hate on that
[Laughter]
right but i'm saying like shorthand
phrasing you have a dark guard
do you want to rip a dart in a car bro
call some cars man what the [ __ ] a guard
in a dark bro that's so stupid i'm not
gonna hate on that
i'm without the guard by the way your
gang
of a human trafficker
but i obviously expect nothing different
of of now come in
um
tate speech i have more to teach pinned
conversation towards the end got so
interesting i'm sure it did
way to part two in all deep topics like
that the girl stuff is funny but world
issues and his insight into that stuff
is crazy yeah the the the saying girls
are a subspecies is that's fine and good
but what i'm really interested in is the
anti-vaxx conspiracies and new world
order stuff that's that's
really compelling
super compelling
i love this one he was world issues
business insight
keep it up boys
yo this guy there's not even any
criticism for him it's awesome
i mean this is a this is a match made in
heaven let's be real the the knelt gang
they're going to be you know what's you
know
they're going to be playing on steak
together i know it
they're gonna be doing a a group steak
trip or some [ __ ]
on darts bro scar
anyway let's watch i can't even get past
this
two seconds of this [ __ ]
high value men bro
you wouldn't wear that shirt you know
it's embarrassing
if you're wearing a high value min man
shirt you know you aren't yes
whatever
if you if you have to tell everyone
you're alpha all the time you are
definitely not dude it's so beta you
gave another man money
to wear a shirt that says you're high
value no
no
no owned you
are we good or can we have the cigars
come in mid show right andrew or you
want to start with the guard we can do
that's one bro yeah it's not a thing i'm
trying to make it a thing just let it
happen just let it happen like it's
throwing on me
maybe a guard in the car yeah he's
really
we're gonna make the garden now or
before you wanna start with the guard
what do we wanna have to guard yeah
what's silver time
just let it happen it's a thing just let
it happen it's a thing now it's a thing
and you know he's beta by the way
he's like stop with the gar [ __ ] bro why
are you saying guard nursing me
make sure she doesn't [ __ ] it up
who's going who's duty is that yeah
who's on who's on cigar duty right now
oh she said chick tash she's supposed to
be getting them is that your
assistant yeah it's a chicken one of my
chicks yeah
one of them one of my wife's i got four
wives i'm from ethiopia
that's one of your wives for real is
that a girlfriend
so wait when you when you bring a girl
when you bring like a girl is she a
girlfriend or just a girl for the trip
girlfriend girlfriend yeah so you like
make her you put her on what is this
part we're watching
that was just uh just showing that
they're going to croatia oh yeah we're
just going down the guard rabbit hole
right there the gar hole yeah yeah so
andrew tate the human trafficker isn't i
i'm assuming i'm taking a guess here
allegedly that he actually can't enter
the united states because he's one for
human trafficking so that's dope loved
that for him
it's a vibe right now
yeah he
he went to ethiopia and asked people do
you have your passports
did you get your shot yeah similar
energy girl wait do you like to come
back with cobra the human trafficker you
have your passport andrew and ethiopia
be like girl would you like to come back
with andrew to america
america
america well croatia yeah yeah romania
do you have your passports
did you get your shots
girl would you like to come back with
andrew to romania
romania
romania
the lawless
do you have your passports
do you want to get human trafficked
girls
[Music]
slavery
i'll take your passport
you're in my basement
romania
yo i love that man yeah
kind of crazy like the slate
the slave trade is kind of still alive
and well
when you think about like
andrew
and r kelly they just go to ethiopia and
literally steal people and lock them in
their basements
yeah and i find it funny how he goes on
all these podcasts like this one in port
noise and it's always talking about how
lenient the romanian government is and
how he says in this podcast at one point
that their cop cars can't even go over
70 miles per hour bugatti whatever and
no wonder they can't catch them um not
only is the slave trade alive and well
but there are an estimated 40 million
people
which is more than three times the
figure during the time that we think of
as like
right are living in some form of modern
slavery i mean obviously the total
population on the planet is much higher
than it was in you know mid 1800s or
whatever but yeah there are more people
slaves on the planet today than at any
other point in history and how many and
what was the number you said 40 million
and how many of those 40 million are
andrew tate's basement oh just a just a
couple
dozen
just a couple dozen yeah that's scary
stop in the bucket that's so scary
that's so sad that's pretty frightening
so sad and scary
a lot of them are probably in gulf
countries like
the work migrant workers and stuff i
don't know though uh i'm sure a lot are
but uh china you
i think you would probably
probably latin america i was gonna say i
think you'd probably be shocked how many
they're over here without [ __ ] that's so
scary
what are we gonna do about it
ow
well yeah i mean everyone in prison is
basically a virtual slave
in america uh good point yeah they're
that yeah
yeah
oh my god
as of 2018 the countries with the most
slaves were india
8 million
china
4 million pakistan
3 million so we actually
shout out america did not top the list
of one of the worst things something
tells me that they are not calling
the slave labor that we have in our
prison system slaves for the purpose of
no counting no of course not if it was i
might skew things a little bit yeah
no we will crush these these rookies
with our slaves prison slave system
but anyway
you know it's kind of crazy all these
people just proudly interviewing him
this is this is equivalent to like
i'm having a hard time drawing a
parallel but i mean
this is like
i don't know having o.j simpson on after
he gets acquitted and
i or well
acquitted well at least he had a trial
yeah at least he had a trial at least he
was technically excited not as bad yeah
numbers i i i yeah lucky numbers yeah we
gotta run some steak after yeah let's do
it bro oh my god they're gonna play
steak i called it you called it yo
a lot about gambling i know about the
odds of gambling i know that there's
absolutely nothing you can do on a
roulette board that affect the odds of
roulette so single zero that's 2.7 i
believe a single zero roulette if you
play for long enough you lose 2.7 of
your money over a long enough period of
time it doesn't matter how you bet
doesn't matter if you bet on one number
all the numbers doesn't matter shut up
okay let's find some good time stem so
tate this this is the one that i saw on
getting around social media [ __ ] blew
my mind yo
oh yeah that's a good one abe
interviewing bin laden after 9 11 being
like yo welcome to the knuck podcast ben
london well
been a lot of
he did he pulled some major numbers but
bin laden welcome to the show
so tell me how many wives do you have no
way bro you got 12 wives that's epic
i think bin laden might have rocked that
milk boy t-shirt maybe he's a bin laden
was a high value male for sure to be
fair yeah yeah yeah that's probably true
i mean did he what was the bounty on his
head he's literally a high i mean he
literally lived in like a in a
in like a
villa
mm-hmm you know he was in like a palace
in pakistan right yeah
do you think he smoked guards there
oh he smells dark
bro he was a gardener
let's hit that guard out in the garden
bro
smoke guard there was a 27 million
dollar bounty on his head that's the
definition of high value
that's it i feel like they would have
put more money on his head
yeah me too 27
the united states government can't do
better than that
you know
anyway
uh here's so this is the clip that blew
my [ __ ] mind and he just says it
right here
you guys brace yourselves man we got him
much experience in life or sat around
some dork for a while or whatever but in
general this is also one of the reasons
men find youth attractive you want to
blow up the internet i'll pull up the
internet right [ __ ] now the reason 18
and 19 year olds are more attractive
than 25 year olds is because they've
been through less dick i'll say this
right here on the [ __ ] internet i
don't give a [ __ ] people sit there and
go you can't see bro we got him
you like young women you could because
they've had less dick bro
your dick has gangrene on it probably at
this point what are you talking about
that's one thing i don't get by the way
i don't get this obsession with these
guys have
with uh
like women who
are children yeah well
i don't i don't care how many people a
woman slept with like at all i don't
understand that it doesn't doesn't make
any sense
especially him who's probably had sex
with [ __ ] you know
everything uh yeah so there you have it
i mean what more do you want to hear a
guy that he gives 25 as the upper bound
for uh
busting an old hag
25 years old that's something busted out
by the way what's the what's the age of
consent in romania
because you know he was like he's just
he said 18 19.
but if he was honest he'd say
yeah 18 18. wow that's very progressive
for romania
i'll put the internet right [ __ ] now
the reason 18 and 19 year olds are more
attractive than 25 year olds is because
they've been through less dig
i don't find 18 and 19 year olds more
trapped than 25 year old speak for
yourself you [ __ ] weird ass yeah just
flat out no dude you're so disgusting oh
my god he's i love how he's he talks
about it like it's just objectively true
yeah like everyone just wants to [ __ ] 18
year olds not 25 year olds
every every dick takes from their life
energy i don't have right another source
of saying 16 for age of consent in
romania i'm not uh yeah that i wasn't
skinny dude that was nuts that's so
weird i mean it admits that yeah some
say 16 some say 18 some say you just
have to have a car faster than 70 miles
per hour and you're good well croatia's
age of consent is 15 so maybe that's why
he's spending time
i was getting scared the reason all men
want women who are 15
other than 25 is because there's have
less dicks in them
you know it's generally much lower in
europe than it is in the united states
though i do need to point that out but i
think they have laws specifically like
so i know in like germany and a lot or i
don't know but there's a lot of like
western european countries with the age
of ken cent being like 15 or 16 but i
think they have to be within a certain
age
there's like kind of like a yeah a
window like a 80 year old germany is 14
as long as the person over the age of 21
does not exploit a 14.
well 21 is still a little high for my
opinion yeah but actually i get that it
makes sense to me that makes more sense
to me than like if a ninth if a 18 year
old has sex with a 17 year old and he
goes afraid like like yeah give me a
[ __ ]
it should be kind of like a sliding
scene but like if you're
in within the same age group you know
age range then then i get it nobody
should go to jail for that yeah i mean
that might be too young to be having sex
in my opinion but i don't think anyone's
life needs to be ruined and they need to
go to jail i mean that's crazy they're
kids yeah
does that make sister sense i mean
regardless james is on that ship oh he
gets andrew's like 35 or something so as
it's all moot anyways
yeah he does not fall within the age
exception not even is not in the window
but the thing you know it's such a
self-report like i could really analyze
this statement that he says proudly
it really just reeks of such
insecurity and anyone that really
understands
what is going on here
psychologically knows that this is a man
who was deeply deeply insecure and
self-loathing he's so intimidated by a
woman that's like experienced or had sex
or been with other guys because he knows
he's inadequate
he knows he's in and he knows that they
will know is the thing that's what he's
afraid of yeah exactly
he's afraid what's so funny i'm sorry
chad i've read a chat that said he he
values girls in [ __ ] years
he values girls and [ __ ] years
interesting that's his like that's his
rubric yeah
[Music]
that's interesting
um
oh yeah yeah like dude you're such a
self-report
i like i'm young and inexperienced
basically he says and that that should
make your skin crawl
and the knuckles are like
yeah for real dude me too bro
women are [ __ ] women are [ __ ] i like
virgins
women are such [ __ ] i like to have sex
with virgins only uh it's gross
can you just think about what you're
saying
it's such a self-report bro you're so
insecure
i mean what other reason would you care
how many women a
dude slept with like i just don't get it
especially when you're like a hyper
sexual you [ __ ] every day you [ __ ]
everything you [ __ ] all the time you got
so many girlfriends and i mean he would
say oh men and women are different
that's fine for a man it's not fine for
a woman which is not i'm not i'm not
even like him by his rules i want to
understand by in reality yeah no reality
yeah just like you said i mean
somebody more experienced that has been
around the block once or twice knows
scariest whole shtick and knows to stay
the [ __ ] away from him scary
he's scared of that
was interesting it's also a form of
control right like it's kind of this
victorian era like
you we don't want women to be sexual we
don't want women to enjoy sex it's not
it's for us to enjoy and it's for them
to procreate
which is weird too like you don't want
them to enjoy having sex with you
somebody said hasn't he said he doesn't
actually enjoy sex i don't know i mean
he said it in this interview what say
what he said like at some at some point
he goes like i don't even know if i
enjoy it anymore
say what let me let me find it
real problems
dude this man is mentally ill like on a
whole another level
anyway let's i gotta watch this part
again and then i i just like gauging
their response too general this is also
one of the reasons men find youth
attractive you want to blow up the
internet i'll pull up the internet right
[ __ ] now the reason 18 and 19 year
olds are more attractive than 25 year
olds is because they've been through
less dick i'll say 25 year old i just i
can't get over that 18 year olds are
more attractive than 25 year olds
according to oh what is this a crazy
thing to say
it's right here on the [ __ ] internet
i don't give a [ __ ] people sit there and
go you can't say that yes i can a 19
year old is more attractive than a 26
year old woman and i'll tell you why oh
my god bro
bro
he's saying 26 is too old for him top g
stands for top groomer by the way yeah
how can you say that it's embarrassing
dude even people go yo everyone thinks
this but they're too afraid to say it no
it's embarrassing
you literally want to [ __ ] children i
mean that's a child in my opinion and
we're pretty close in age i'm only two
years older than you
not available trying to date right
hypothetically
thank you in minecraft in minecraft
gerold has talked to more guys been to
the club more times been more places
been [ __ ] and dumped more times more
arguments more heartbreak more [ __ ]
yes life experience yes
growing as a person becoming more
experienced yes like literally what he's
rattling off is like you can't [ __ ]
them yes you can't just [ __ ] lie to
them
you mean you mean they're more closer to
an adult and not a child right yeah i
like to [ __ ] kids because they believe
everything i say and they're much more
easier to manipulate
he really tells you everything nothing
he's just self-reporting i know even if
you like andrew
right like these guys do you would think
that in the interest of having an
interesting conversation you would at
least
ask for a follow-up question on that i
mean let's hear what they where they
take this me to clean up whereas a 19
year old might have had one guy from
high school just broke up she's fresh
and i could [ __ ] put my imprint on
her make her a good person and without
her having to go a good person um dude
right in front i did not like that word
oh my god dude how is he saying this
through all that detriment to learn
about life so what's your key age range
19 it's not it's not just about the
adrenaline no i know but what's your
what's your what's your preference i
mean hot girls are hot girls right i
don't know hot girls are hot girls so
what the [ __ ] did you just say but my
point is that older women
the reason they're less attractive to
men even in men so just just to again
reiterate
older women 25.
just
one foot in the grave at that point
so so just just to really let that
resonate in you how haul did you just
turn olivia on your birthday last week
i'm 23 i don't know two years you only
have two years
expired
no but he [ __ ] he's [ __ ] children i
mean if 25 is too old you know
that's when like the priest like is
graduates you and it's like you know
time for some new fresh meat don't
instinctually understand it it's because
they've been through a whole bunch more
[ __ ] and we're not interested in dealing
with someone else's problems if you get
with a girl who's 26 27 she's gonna be
sitting there going i know men like you
i've seen what men yes self [ __ ]
report absolutely that's right i can't
believe he's so dumb to openly say this
young girls are easy to take advantage
of
because they know less yeah because they
have less life experience and they
haven't slept with other men so they
don't oh my god
this is such a self-report
[ __ ]
and like you do you ain't going out
i don't like that
what you're agreeing
i don't like that i agree
what the [ __ ] i don't like when women
say that i don't like when women are
dead
this [ __ ] just said i agree
the 26 year old woman and i'll tell you
why because that 26 year old has talked
to more guys been to the club more times
been more places been [ __ ] and dumped
more times more arguments more
heartbreak more [ __ ] more mess for
me to clean up whereas a 19 year old
might have had one guy from high school
just broke up she's fresh and i can
[ __ ] put my imprint on her make her a
good person and without her having to go
through all that detriment to learn
about life so what's your key age range
19 they're less attractive to men even
if men don't instinctually understand it
it's because they've been through a
whole bunch more [ __ ] and we're not
interested in dealing with someone
else's problems if you get with a girl
who's 26 27 she's gonna be sitting there
going i know men like you i've seen what
men like you do you ain't going out
i don't like that
i [ __ ] love this dude he's sitting
there with a car talking about i don't
like that i don't like women who say
[ __ ] like
who are experienced
what is this [ __ ] delusion that like
older women that have been in lots of
relationships and like have life
experience are are like
more
likely to
cause you problems and and uh be
emotional or whatever than a well then
an 18 year old girl right right right
because because it's different yeah
you're right but it's different you know
yeah the problems are all on his end
because of his insecurities right that's
a great point
it's all different for him
oh my god
babe was he bigger than what
this is this is literally by the way
this podcast is single-handedly
destroying a whole generation of young
men
[ __ ] untold
ripples
from this you're telling me you were
innocent and sweet ripple dart rip a
dart ripple dart bro get a gar
what are they selling back here by the
way
uh supplements protein baby
why are you buying protein from full
scent do you really think they're making
the best protein powder which one of
these guys does the scientists tell me
yeah which one of these is a [ __ ]
food scientist chemist
you know what i mean damn why the [ __ ]
you buying fulson supplements
sleep you go buy sleeping pills from
full send
rip a [ __ ] dart be your last start i
don't i don't like full send dudes
selling sleeping pills one bit i don't
like the implication of that at all
next thing you know here baby
[ __ ] dude
i cannot believe these guys are real man
for this dude you were nice to him he
[ __ ] you and messed you up and now i
deal with the attitude problem you've
developed because he got your [ __ ] i
didn't want him to [ __ ] you in the first
place you should've been a virgin when
you met me now i'm dealing with your
[ __ ]
also why would you
an experienced uh sex have her
want to want to have sex with a virgin
that's like a that's just like a whole
thing right like it's like a whole
emotional thing
it's a whole process
why is that an experience you're looking
for i don't i don't know
it's all just manipulation
he wants them like bonded him this man
is so [ __ ] mentally ill and if you
cannot tell that
oh my god you guys
[ __ ] goodbye
don't you think though the you know
trying to find purity out of women it
kind of is like a low possibility i mean
it's kind of like when a woman says i
want a guy that's like mother [ __ ]
this guy's looking for women with purity
but it's rare he says this guy's
agreeing i want women who are pure
you [ __ ] dude what
what
what
that's like six feet tall whatever the
case may be right you know trying to
find purity out of women it kind of is
like a low possibility i mean it's kind
of like when a woman says i want a guy
that's like six feet tall whatever the
case
i cannot [ __ ] believe is
he's like somewhat
in a very weak way pushing back on him
there
a little well he's no but he's accepting
the premise that men want purity in
women
like women want a tall guy it's just not
true
sure i mean right that's true but okay
let's hear but it's still like the most
pushback i've seen i'm not all in in
this whole thing that we've been
watching let's see which may be right
there's less of them and like it's like
dude you can't really find a virgin the
best things in the world are low
probability it doesn't mean it's not
what we desire we're talking about we
what we desire i just i don't like that
he accept the premise that men just want
to [ __ ] virgin yeah that and that's
obviously just gross and weird not
[ __ ] true
and what i'm saying is that one of the
best things about status is that you can
now get what you desire so at status
most men have this dream of sleep with
endless women i could if i decided could
sleep with a new woman every single day
for the next 10 years all i would have
to do is reply to my instagram inbox it
would not be difficult i could do it
it's not interesting to me
i am more interested in using my status
to find something extremely rare like a
woman of innocence
right oh you sound so
[ __ ] yikes dude
i can't [ __ ] believe this
how are you saying this oh my god
holy [ __ ]
a woman of innocence
who's 18 by the way or maybe as long as
as young as the laws allow
wow
let's move on to another time stamp
that's just nuts
tate describing what men are attracted
to well i mean it's not about i don't
know
i think we already covered that one oh
we already hit this yeah
uh tate talking about how feminists are
ugly
jesus interested i recently heard matt
gates uh
yeah
similar take actually yeah he goes matt
gates he's a is he congressman or
senator from florida congressman
he goes
what's the deal with all these women who
are uh pro-abortion nobody what's the
problem is that nobody's gonna want to
[ __ ] them anyway so they don't even need
abortion because they're so ugly and
what
and what a coincidence matt gates also
under investigation for sex trafficking
super interesting whoa
an open investigation it's a 16 year old
girl i believe if remember well that's
the perfect age innocent pure yeah
virgin
did you [ __ ] you what is the virgin
thing like this it's just besides the
point but it's just
like
not
not all men want virgins like that's
just that i think it must it's the
opposite no i don't want to [ __ ] deal
with it i think it's a sadist thing like
you like and as i unders i've never
actually had sex with a virgin but as i
understand it it's very painful the
first time yeah and so they like that i
mean they they like that it's not like
good
i i don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about that all men want that
that's just [ __ ] nonsense
it's incredible stuff here's matt gates
by the way
uh with us a great take our fine
representative from florida he's pro
abortion pro-murder rallies the people
are just disgusting
like bro have you looked in the mirror
you are the goofiest toothiest [ __ ]
freak of a human being i have ever seen
you have like uh mr mackey syndrome your
tie is so tight your head [ __ ]
expanded
you look ridiculous dude
why is it
that the
oh thank you for pulling that up
thank you man
of course this dude is calling women
ugly
it's just beautiful
it's so good
women with the least likelihood of
getting pregnant are the ones most
worried about having abortions
this is the guy by the way
this one has to be edited
is this real
i mean maybe not it looks real to me
this is from congress.gov
[Laughter]
oh man what's the deal with all these
pro-abortion women being ugly
and he gets why 16 year old women are
more attractive they're easy
to manipulate
a woman his age would never want
anything to do with this [ __ ]
disgusting
lunatic a small small correction
the girl was 17 not 16 with matt gates
so oh okay matt gates okay 17 year old
not a 16 year old okay small correction
thank you dan
we'll see you in court
yeah
just to impregnate you if you look like
a thumb
[Applause]
these people you are a thumb bro
the only reason he's saying that is
because he must have been called that so
many times in his life bro you are a
thumb oh my god
on the inside and out they're like five
to
350 pounds and they're like give me my
abortions or i'll get up in march and
protest and i'm thinking march
you look like you got ankles weaker than
the legal reasoning behind roe versus
wade
yeah a really strong argument there
you gotta stop that a little bit
that did not land ankles stronger than
yo i think you've got to work on if your
argument and supporting uh a abortion
ban is that
people who want abortion are fatties
and disgusting it's just not it's not
that good
yeah few of them need to get up in march
they need to get up and march for like
an hour a day swing those arms turn into
a fat people routine mud pumping maybe
mix in a salad
that was us representative matt gates
what a [ __ ] legend man him and tate
would actually get on quite well so
here's andrew tate with a similar point
here
uh talking about how feminists are ugly
it's actually very unfortunate it's kind
of unfortunate because women are
completely and utterly solely judged on
how they look
like a lot of these feminists are
[ __ ] they're so busted
like you if you're gonna be a feminist
at least get hot first because if you're
hot you'll matter oh the hot [ __ ] said
this you ever think that
no one cares nobody cares your uglies
just nobody cares i understand why
you're mad
i'm me and the hot [ __ ] with me i get
it you're mad at god that's fine but
dude but what do you do cancel me i
don't care make a video keep making
videos i don't care there's a direct
correlation no i'm not canceling you but
there's a reason this isn't happening we
are making from the united states
it's because you're wanted
let's hear what they say about that in
between that right hot girls aren't
going to come after you but the ugly
ones will hot well hot girls hot girls
dude you look at you
look at you
look at you hey well well we can't call
him an incel
you're a misogynist like it's just a
circle they don't have any weapons yeah
they have no weapons against me how are
you gonna sit there to the dude sit with
a bunch of beautiful women in his
mansion and then say you're you're
sexist you're ugly you're a three these
chicks are hot and they chose me i don't
give a [ __ ] what you say
i'm not interested you talk about it a
lot for something you don't give a [ __ ]
about you know what's so sad
he really just wants to be loved yeah
yeah he pays these women to be there
and he actually just wants a woman to
choose him for the right reason and
that's what's so sad about andrew tate
because a fat [ __ ] idiot like me
a woman chose me andrew damn and i
didn't even have money at the time
and that's what he wants man he wants
someone to really love him for who he is
and i just you know
he's never gonna get it at this point
man yeah ship sailed he's over the 25
hump unfortunately so he's not he's he's
never gone
a high-value female
at 30. the first woman that didn't love
him was
his mother yeah
true
and he's been chasing that kind
of that motherly love ever since and
he's just
it's mommy make-out day
he tries to show to the world hey look i
got chicks all around me
but deep inside we know what he wants
there's one chick that isn't around him
his mom
i was gonna say his soul mate
[ __ ] your mom yeah and his mom who and
his mom
[ __ ] your mom
it might be the thing it's actually very
unfortunate kind of
keep the sound sad music going it makes
more sense when you listen to this
unfortunate because women are completely
and utterly solely judged on how they
look
like all these feminists are [ __ ]
they're so black and white on the screen
like
um
this makes so much more sense with the
sad music can you turn up the sad music
a bit zach
if you're gonna be a feminist at least
get hot first because if you're hot
you'll ma but you turned up his music
his volume too just
just as sad
you can't split them
you can
you can't split the audio coming from
your soundboard just turn up your
soundboard
here right there
oh the hot [ __ ] said this now it's out
of control the levels are out of control
[Music]
no one cares nobody cares you're ugly
it's just nobody cares i understand why
you're mad
i'm me and the hot pictures of me i get
it you're mad at god that's fine but but
what do you do cancel me i don't care
make a video keep making videos i don't
care there's a direct correlation
between that right hot girls aren't
going to come after you but the ugly
ones will nobody wants to [ __ ] you bro
trust me
look at this guy yo i'm totally with you
bro
[Music]
hot chicks are so
ugly chicks are so lame
[Music]
hot hot girls hot girls love
men
who are prepared to protect provide take
care of them
only hot women
if you're prepared to protect provide
and take care to a degree you see
yourself in a position of authority to a
degree right it's my i need to take care
of her i'm gonna pay her rent she's
gonna come on my boat she's going to
listen to me she's going to be
the implications of course
i can't get over that
see yourself
in a position of authorities which means
to some degree you are misogynistic
women beautiful women love misogynistic
men when you see a 19 year old ukrainian
on a billionaire's yaw in dubai is she
complaining that he's the boss and he's
in charge or she like oh i'm glad he
bought this bow i don't know how boats
work i just want to [ __ ] it obviously
that's why he picked her up dum-dum
anyway yeah it makes a lot more sense
with the sad music
uh olivia you said is he is it public
who these girls are he puts up with no
because they're human trafficked
he doesn't want to put him out because
then their parents will know where they
are right and they'll send the embassy
after him yeah because if he was i would
like kill to listen to these girls that
he says oh so compliant with oh he would
never let them anywhere near a
microphone or phone right
by the way
you can kill the sad music thank you
zach
i'm not going to spend money on this i
want to this is young tate yep
interesting alpha as [ __ ] yeah you don't
look so alpha dude i'm not gonna spend
money on this i want to how much have
you got left to get andrew he's got
loads you have got loads of his tim
chief
this is uh from big brother i believe
um
right he was a reality star
he got kicked off the show for
hitting somebody getting in a fight or
something doesn't surprise me he is
mentally ill
i don't remember exactly what the story
was but
he
andrew tate refuses to pay for lunch and
they posting this like it's a dub oh
look at all the comments another tate w
all right let me watch this [ __ ] it's
awesome
i just think it would be nice
to you know
buy
chloe is unaware that andrew is hoarding
his extra money for next week when he
hopes to be traveling with people he
gets on with better
people
wanting chloe to stop asking him for
money andrew who also handed in some
laundry when he arrived at the hostel
let's get us claimed that's how i was
going to ask i just type in that that's
not worth it
basically summary is he hid the money
so that when she asked for it wasn't
there so he didn't have to pay yeah
whatever they're playing the game i
don't really care
uh moving on to
uh tate discusses having multiple women
gino
vagina
one hoe is too close to noho so we're
not gonna go down that road with five
but five is enough to give me a buffer
space to replace one if she gets out of
line whatever give me five chicks i'll
settle down right now but to actually be
running out there and just really
tearing through it i just think maybe
i'm just bored of the game maybe maybe
it got too easy
but i i don't know even sex in and of
itself i just think is it that good you
don't think one woman could please you
do you hear that like fully yeah he
wants love is that a sex even that good
yeah
i
want love
but it's impossible
you know that video with robbie robert
downey jr
the elton john song they should do it
with andrew tate i can't show it
obviously you get claimed it's just
robert downey jr walking in black and
white through a giant mansion singing it
it's really corny to be honest i don't
like it as a music video but i love the
song
and i think it would really suit andrew
i
want love but it's impossible
a man like me
so irresponsible
a man like me is dead in places
it's such a perfect song look at this
yeah
that other men
feel liberated
and i want love
josh bolo holes
this is so true
shout out john though love his ass
it's so so obvious you supposed to be
loved man
i don't think one woman is capable of
completing a man's life absolutely no i
think you need a wife sexually sex but i
think i think you need a wife and you
need hoes
[Laughter]
dan you're missing the best part man
he says you need here i'll go back for
you this is important stuff dan yeah
come on
i don't think one woman is capable of
completing a man's life absolutely no i
think you need a wife sexually but i
think i think you need a wife and you
need hoes yeah you need both i don't
think there's times
cause i mean i love that these little
[ __ ] [ __ ] are agreeing like these
guys are so pathetic dude what the [ __ ]
there are times where you're like i mean
there are times where you do
at least kyle's not like saying [ __ ]
i just love it bro you're so funny it's
true i think uh i think with five wives
things around the house things in
general just be more efficient you know
the best thing about dude these people i
don't think any of these guys have ever
been in a serious relationship
all of them have never been close enough
to a woman
so
you know what i mean wait there's a
really funny angle on tate's face where
you can see what a gremlin he is
i'm trying to go back and find the exact
frame
you can really tell what kind of his
face is all grambling out
it's somewhere here
yeah somewhere around here
i guess it's not as good as the last one
we saw
it's not as good
things around the house things in
general would just be more efficient you
know the best thing about having
multiple women i'll tell you from my
webcam days
do they interact with each other do you
sell oh no they're super interactive
because i only told like twenty do they
get jealous though do they have separate
cells
yeah they have their own stuff
they could talk through the bars they
super interacted
they they could jingle a tin can on the
cell bars
[Music]
[Laughter]
but it's hard to get jealous this is
about the social paradigm it's hard they
of course they got jealous and i would
reassure them until everything's okay
but they would never disrespect me
openly because no one else did you don't
be the only disrespectful [ __ ]
then you get kicked out
you know it's not it's not it's not the
society
is that the prison door closing
that's what happens if he comes to
america
to norm
this is why in america everyone's fat
because it's normal you go to russia or
ukraine there's very few fat people
because you don't want to be seen fat
because no one's fat so everyone's going
to be like what the [ __ ] you obese for
do you understand what i'm saying it's a
societal norm if every chick is coming
up to me and treating me like god you
don't be the only chick with an attitude
because you feel embarrassed
plus yeah of course i had that plus you
get kicked out yeah
i get your i get your strategy now girls
get kicked out and then when they got
kicked out i feel like in a way to
compliment kyle the manlet
that he's actually the only one who's
like he's nervously laughing and not
saying anything
which is kind of surprising
that he seems to be the one that knows
how crazy it is what he's saying while
the other two guys are just writing for
a
potential new bestie
kyle new bestie it's in the air
happy dad happy dad happy papa
i could see it i could see a room for
that maybe what do you guys think
maybe not yet maybe not
[ __ ] this is not good i could see it
maybe a potential bestie path for us
[Laughter]
let's wait till wednesday and then we
could decide okay right yeah only i got
three new besties to add it's a lot for
me yeah
they'd fail because they're naturally
lazy so then when a girl when the girl
got kicked out we'd have a we'd have a
party every time every time i fired a
[ __ ] we'd have a party
sort of a party
and and not make fun of her but just
like one less hoe
last one standing gets the sun we speak
a joke and all this [ __ ] so we kicked
the girl out we have a party and and
girls would instantly not like turn on
her but girls are tribal right she's no
longer part of the tribe she's she's
stupid sounds like a cult dude like
actually uh
yep yeah i i missed that did he say last
one standing gets to see the sun he said
last one gets his son like i'll get you
pregnant oh yeah it's the last one
standing gets to see the sun yeah
we had a party right in the basement
these [ __ ] haven't seen the sun in
years
and we'd all kind of think and the part
of the party is we we'd monitor her
monitor her on camera so every day after
she left we'd check on how well she was
doing how you can see them online how
many hours they do they're ranking on
the website how much money they're
making
and they go from way up here making
millions to just slowly declining
because they're lazy they're lazy
they're lazy they fall off and end up
down to nothing and then beg for their
job back
so that's
there's no way that's all true by the
way
this shit's nuts
i mean this is like interviewing pablo
escobar it's like
they're like you oh no it's way worse
father escobar
opened schools and stuff
at least he did cherry
yeah okay okay shout out pablo yeah i
know people love pablo
he was like a folk hero where he's from
yeah yeah and that's true that's true
[ __ ] okay i'm still looking for a good
analogy then
pablo escobar what about el chapo
maybe maybe el chaporino
big chops
what's up big chops dab me up
so so now girls are like if i leave he's
gonna party he's gonna make fun of me
and i'm gonna make any money and i'm
gonna be another one the ones they mock
and dinner so now girls don't want to
lose their job right so so he's talking
about the psychological
manipulation he he employs
to keep women complicit
in this webcam scheme
and sex slavery slash human trafficking
he's laying it all out there
fbi is taking notes
right
so
girls didn't really disrespect me but we
were talking about um of them being
jealous yeah but i was about to say one
of the best things about living with
multiple women this is actually the best
thing about it the best thing about
living with multiple women is that all
the girl [ __ ] they do together
so your girl if she right now if you
have a girlfriend she has a group of
friends all of those friends are your
enemy every single oh my god
you are so [ __ ] mentally ill
i can't deal with this
they're the reason they're your enemy is
because every relationship you've ever
been in you're trying to isolate them
you're like you know what i mean
and all of her friends are begging her
to to not be with you
he's that guy that that yeah he's that
total cult behavior
he's that guy that tries to isolate
you from your friends and family
that's like totally [ __ ] crazy
the thing they say to her is bad about
you he doesn't let you go out hey why is
he asking where you are why is he
calling you it's only a boat party let's
go here they're all negative you don't
want your woman talking to them that's
true
the same four girls she's like obsessed
like she goes out and he's like a
jealous boyfriend calling every two
seconds like where are you where are you
what are you doing what are you doing
yeah yeah so insecure bro
oh my god it
i would love to have like a
a shrink watch this whole thing and
analyze yeah
that'd be kind of dumb
maybe a little unprofessional though
if you're [ __ ] the same four girls
then her friendship circle are all
behaving and all you're positive towards
you now so you don't have that negative
influence well i i can't get over this
is literally like r kelly i mean yeah
this is r kelly textbook this is this is
exactly what's happening it's worse
though because he
has r kelly well
i don't know if it's worse or kelly did
some bad [ __ ] but
he wasn't like putting him on webcams
[Laughter]
this is r kelly people want dr drew back
to analyze the tate phenomenon
he's gonna start defending tate
maybe he could bring peace between the
two of you
you and tate maybe
maybe ethan
you're a cook
obviously listen ethan i have to break
it to you you are a bit of a [ __ ] guy
he's like please just stop being a beta
for a second
[Laughter]
listen he has a point ethan he's right
the the psychology of women is uh when
they all get together
um
yeah which means every once in a while i
see somebody in the chat insisting that
it's all an act no it's not he lives
this life and
the thing is even if it was even if we
just went with that assumption for a
second
the people
in these comments the people signing up
for hustler university or whatever
they don't believe that they believe
every word so
whether or not it's an act is sort of
secondary to the impact that he's having
and the message that he's trying to
spread to people right i don't know if
this is like tate stands who are trying
to push that what is your evidence that
it's an act he did have a webcam service
where he had multiple women
right he was raided by the
romanian police on a tip that he was
human trafficking people against their
will so
so which part is an act
like
tell me
if you're gonna say it's a [ __ ] act
you better have some evidence
uh because last time i checked
you don't get rated
by the romanian swat team for fun
but yeah you make a good point either
way
the the result is the same
yeah but there's no [ __ ] way
that it's an act and i'm sorry if you're
like a tate a little tater tot
and you want to convince yourself that
he's actually just doing a bit
and i mean there's tater tots yeah no i
think people call him yeah
but yeah i mean i think that there are a
lot of people that do think it's just an
act and
i mean we're inferring a lot from just a
little bit of footage of kyle but i the
way that he's like you're so funny man
and he's just kind of like nervously
laughing i think he may like perceive it
as just like oh this is just like this
put on persona or whatever but again
the
the people that are paying fifty dollars
a month they don't think that they're
not paying fifty dollars a month for for
a shtick
they're trying to gain knowledge from
this guy yeah so
it's kind of irrelevant there's
literally no evidence to say this is an
act
like he he really lives the life he's
saying
um
and it's not good
so just saying
your friends all the time you have a
girlfriend you don't want to send her
away with friends because they're up to
bad [ __ ] i love sending my girls away oh
you want your nails done go boom oh you
wanna go see that [ __ ] movie go go go
the security oh oh you wanna go go leave
me the [ __ ] alone go you wanna go ikea
we need towels cool no go to ikea you're
calling every ten minutes asking where
they are yeah where are you where are
you literally you got to hear that dude
send me a picture of you at ikea so i
know you're not somewhere else right
insecure
oh he tracks them
oh yeah they all have apps yeah yeah
yeah
and that's the that's this tragedy of
this just one call to make sure they
don't lie absolutely even though he
knows [ __ ] be lying
they say they'd be shopping
they'd be lying show me ikea show me the
fika
it's the tragedy is that he just wants
to be loved and he just he
he's just so insecure that he doesn't
trust women which is kind of just so
crazy to go buy towels without wanting
to go [ __ ]
the company of another man
uh and the sad thing he's probably right
because they're desperate to like get
out of her of like uh sex trafficking
why do all these women want to leave
oh [ __ ] men have to do i see men doing
all this dumb [ __ ] with their chick
because they don't want her to do with
their friends man i've been ikea in a
long time ikea is the most depressing
place on the planet what if you're going
to get sucks wait wait you're wrong
i still hear that
ikea sucks
yo you got some [ __ ] to say about these
guys hating on ikea i hate ikea i'm
sorry i've heard tate hate on sweden a
couple times before so i gotta give him
a big [ __ ] you dude
um you better not come here dude
brother
you know
you heard it here andrew tate love says
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you bro
[ __ ] you andrew tate from love himself
representing all of sweden yes they
kindly ask you with respect and peace
and love to suck their [ __ ]
swedish super strong [ __ ]
oh yeah baby meatballs baby [ __ ]
[ __ ] how about a fika on this dick
[ __ ]
how about that
[Laughter]
snack time [ __ ] down here
andrew tate
young finger thank you for the three
gift of the row
oh by the way
we i i i
i talked to ninja i heard i heard this
is an exciting update
wait holy [ __ ]
i'm in a group chat with tana jeff and
mike now
holy [ __ ]
i gotta send them the let's [ __ ] go
uh
do people know what that is or people
think i'm weird when i send that
the the the baseball on fire the
screaming let's [ __ ] go i mean it's
been a meme for a while but i i don't
know do you not like it you were the
first person to send it to me i've never
seen did you laugh when you saw it
you don't like it you know strongly
wait it's a classic though that's a
classic yeah i mean that's well known i
absolutely love that [ __ ] meme
oh yeah yeah this is here i'll pull it
up for our audience this is what i'm
sending to break the ice
this is how much i believe in this meme
yeah pull it up dan and it's got like
the watermark over it yeah this thing's
classic let's [ __ ] go
olivia gave up
you don't love it it's a little bit
boomer
what not bad that's totally not bloomer
what boom are you sending like that
it's a twitchy mode i'd say it's sumo
yeah yeah
yeah i you just exposed you guys are
probably right but honestly when i first
saw it i got the same vibes as olivia
thank you boomers would not this is like
meta boomer meme it's meta boomer like
okay intentionally having the watermark
on there and stuff like that boomer
would never send like a screaming
[ __ ] tennis ball it's like halfway
deep fried
there are deep fried versions of it i
see that times like here here
see that one's way funnier i think
for some reason just because you like a
deep fried like the fried i don't like
i feel like the deep fried means
hey this is ironic right not this one
no i don't i like the original i'm like
i like the original flavor keep it pure
you like purity huh
yes
you have the picture in like your
favorites
and your camera roll it's like in your
favorites
i think he just posts it so often that
it's always in the recess
oh it's in the recent yeah
oh we got a poll somebody put up a poll
is it boomer yes or no dude you better
not spell yes because you guys are
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know that's yeah i
don't think this paul this is a bad poll
because would your parents ever send you
that no never mind my millennial like i
don't even get it sibling would though
i'm millennial okay
how's that boomer olivia don't stop
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're two we're two generations removed
from boomer yeah there's like gen x
memes and then you get to the yes but
you guys are lame you guys don't know
what you're seeing
whoever made this is this is a bad poll
it is a bad pull because it's there
is it boomer oh yes but it's like ironic
boom let's go what oh why are you
high-fiving oh we just mean a little bit
it's a bad pull you guys this is a bad
poll yeah you guys it's always a bad
poll when it's not in favor of what you
guys want i cannot believe y'all i am
the king of bad polls around yeah but i
i you let your bias effectively say it's
time i send that meme to everybody all
the time yeah i mean it's a it's a good
meme it's a franker c tv emote i mean
this is this is the sumerest of emotes
in my opinion exactly thank you love
you're the biggest zoomer
there's a deer okay it's usually deep
fried there's a stock footage overlay
like yeah
i don't know if you're a good zoomer
representative you you're not a twitcher
you're not a juicer you like old-timers
i got you i mean
you might be the most boomer out of all
of us
in the context of this group chat
who who are they most likely to think
like who's tana most likely to think
like us or olivia
they're definitely on more of the same
wavelength am i so am i supposed to
somehow like a paragon of zoomerism yeah
she is really sorry
am i supposed to tell me let me ask you
a question am i supposed to be myself or
try to get in the mind oh my god no of
everybody they're talking be yourself oh
really because you guys are saying ethan
don't be yourself no that's actually
that's not what i'm saying at all you
were you said hey how do you feel about
this emote and i was like
and then you asked and i answered i take
it personally because you're saying you
don't like me you don't like an
extension of hawaii no i take it i love
it
that's actually my favorite text that
you sent yeah too late the damage is
done no why are you trying to impress
them they should be trying to impress
you you they're fighting for your love
it's not the other way around this is a
fantastic
big camera you think i've offended them
that much that uh i should be begging
them to forgive me
they better send some zoomer [ __ ] back
to you that's all i'm saying um
so
uh anyway
andrew tate's a tool he's insecure
he really just wants to be loved and
that's the biggest tragedy of all
by the way and so ninja
ninja and his wife slash manager
followed me
at the same time
and i took the opportunity to send them
a message
and he wrote me back a really nice
message
and then i asked if he wanted to call on
the show real fast for a low wholesome
segment and he he didn't he goes to me
but i get it that's fine
i would i would ghost myself
he's a busy man he's a very busy man
yeah he's busy he's got dubs to get
you wanna say what your idea was because
i thought it was pretty brilliant oh i
wanted to have a ninja competition
because you guys know you got these guys
are super into fortnite
the dream team fortnite guys is love
love is like really good apparently
loves a juicer maybe
sam and ian right keep leaving
and cameron i keep i don't know why i
keep cameron cameron's quite good as
well ap doesn't even have the ninja skin
dude
[Music]
i don't even play for him
oh l's in the chat lane after all this
you don't have that yeah let me let me i
wonder i'll comment on the show question
guys that i play with every day no one
told me about it i totally i wasn't it
was in our group chat at all oh wow
ninja skin because it's important
you shake the item shop every day bro
yeah someone have to hey hey maybe
does someone have to tell you to breathe
to [ __ ] i think i'm mad about the
let's go meme
let me recover though that being said
i'm the worst fortnite player in the mix
here a b would cream me every time i
would cream you can
anyway my idea was
to get ninja in a custom lobby with all
you five guys and see if u5 vs ninja can
take him that'd be interesting he would
destroy us i think so too but it'll be
fun right without me in there yeah they
would definitely because you say you're
pretty good
loves crap
i mean i i play a lot of games you know
i have like five five six thousand so
thousand dollars on cs go oh yeah four
thousand on call of duty right so i've
spent the larger amount of my childhood
playing fps games
so that's probably why but i haven't
played that much fortnight i will say
though i've seen the most amazing thing
i've ever seen in fortnite by love i
mean i'm just glad cam witnessed it too
but i've seen his character do a
backflip like neo which isn't even
possible in the game he did an emo
uh
love you did a backflip in the game he
jumped over a bullet like neo and what
he did was he like spammed an email or
something but it happened so fast that
the animation didn't show up are you
serious so he like jumped over the
bullet and i was like what the [ __ ] is
going on it was unbelievable yeah and
that's a that's a legit strategy you can
employ if you're like
no it sounds like a spider sense you
know i'm like [ __ ] i'm in the situation
and boom it just happened you know it
just happened
yeah
let's go
[Music]
i mean
you can hardly call that a dance right
excuse me i'm we're best season on i
mean this with peace and love but how
can you call that a day why are you
going down this road again
okay
do i have to play the song bite do i
have to play the wholesome sound bite
give me shout out to my family ethan a b
cam dan
gila ian laina olivia sam zack
it's so wholesome can you play the one
where he says my name
ethan klein thank you for the five
dollar donut
you're welcome brother i think the gift
of
the good food
ian slater with you what's up
i was actually just shouting out a
little bit with him earlier today
you guys look like dogs now you're
always talking to the ninja you're
making me jealous love
[ __ ]
a little bit more you know yo shout out
thank you for the 10 gifted thank you
love for the young gifted
brett really did give 10 uh membership
so
let me get the baby
thank you for the gift bro he gave me
the best shout out over the weekend but
he didn't upload the vod so my video is
really shitty but
hold up i want to see it's not it's not
letting me send it for some reason i can
play it if you want brett thank you for
10 gifted yeah
favorite flavor
vanilla but i saw this already we didn't
show it on the show oh yeah
so you did a little freestyle for you
yeah
okay thank you
thank you for the 10 subs
lena thank you for the gifted
but really thank you brett
is that it
yeah brady boy
well
that's about it eh i mean
it's about what you expected from these
goons
you know
they did gift us with gars though i'm
not gonna go garden cars
i can't wait to go
watching garfield my guy
if that means watch garfield in the
guard and smoke cars bro
if that meme said let's [ __ ] gar
cam can you make that yeah yeah i got
you he's honest he's on it he's on it
because i can send them five [ __ ] by
themselves i went to ikea about three
years ago and i genuinely by the way
this guy's a piece of [ __ ] i can tell i
remember once in a previous episode he's
like before no i wouldn't couldn't get
laid at all and now
i [ __ ] like hundreds of [ __ ] it's
about like i get it dead sick i get what
you're doing sick dude
humanly think oh it's sick it was one of
the most depressing experiences of mine
yeah that's fine i saw full-grown men so
busy and [ __ ] too
they're so busy they're so busy in there
something killed zach yeah i know oh my
god i think zach heard a joke in his
head no he's like it's so busy
that's why he won't go
let me go back and see if i missed
something here exactly who's got it and
i genuinely think
it was one of the most depressing
experiences of mine yeah that's funny i
saw full grown men so busy hey what is
he talking about they're busy and [ __ ] i
mean it is ikea oh like oh they're going
on and on about ikea yeah
wait let me go back to that comment was
like yo that intellectual conversation
guys at the end of the podcast was super
interesting
ikea's [ __ ] crowded man yeah
that's the worst day of my life kia is
the most depressing place on the planet
what if you guys suck wait wait you're
wrong
if you go to ikea with five wives even
worse wow i'll take good because i can
send them five [ __ ] by themselves i
went to ikea about three years ago
i went to a furniture store about three
years ago [ __ ] fascinating bro
three years maybe it was three and a
half years ago
let me know let me hear this anecdote
this is good stuff genuinely think
it was one of the most depressing
experiences of mine yeah that's fine i
saw a fool shut up
[ __ ] boy let him talk
nobody cares that you hate ikea
why don't you just lay down at this
point i mean i'm not going to talk
all right
what is bro hello i have been note like
all all their cameras are like at crotch
level did you notice this yeah
all of their singles
like the camera is just like kind of
right bro
right at crotch level yo that's uh it's
not the most flattering it's grown men
so busy and [ __ ] too i'm just amazed i
saw full-grown men
on a sunday morning walking around about
the ikea hot dogs though
yo i love the high level conversation at
the end it was super interesting
that's loving it laughing
this is like he wants to just throw
something in so bad yeah it's real busy
there oh dude
you know where it's at the billion
dollar company is real busy there man
right
but the sadness the sadness in the eyes
of the full-grown man on a sunday
morning walking around and his wife is
like picking up a towel you want this
towel or this towel and you can see he
doesn't give a solitary [ __ ] it's his
only day off it's his only day off he's
been working for six days and she's like
we need to go ikea steve he's like ah
can't we not go we need towels steve
he's like oh maybe i might get laid next
month if i go ikea and he's standing
there and she's like which towel steve
and he's the guy like carrying the baby
oh i don't know which one do you like
babe i'm like oh this whole place is
just depressing you know what's crazy is
that he's going to die by himself
you know it's just like yeah it's so
baited
next month it's so baited to hold you
by the romanian mob you know what's
crazy also
is i don't think i know any girl who
enjoys shopping for towels
like it's a chore that's not something
yeah nobody likes to go out and do it
while being responsible and like you
know taking care of your children i like
how he throws that he's holding a baby
right yeah
that's beta for holding your child
that's real [ __ ] he actually probably
does think that
that's a woman's job put in the stroller
give her some bubble water whoa whoa
whoa whoa is that baby drinking formula
no no no bubble what
about government
you don't let another man suck your
titty that's my titty you three that
baby bubba what up
[ __ ] jealous it's jealous of the baby
those titties are mine [ __ ] yeah it's
real busy in there
[Music]
all right we gotta go
thank you guys
uh so wednesday's gonna be the bonanza
let's see if it goes through
i mean i just got added to the group
chat group chat is a good sign yeah you
just got added and you sent that meme
yeah maybe they were
once they saw feel bad i'm kidding
it's a slave no the whole chat was
saying lb you're either on the right cam
about the elderly's ela said nice work
cam that ate it that edit made it look
wholesome wait
i just
oh boy
wait what it might be war with the milk
boys after we uh go off the air oh no
because i'm seeing we detected copyright
audio and video in your stream you met
your stream may be temporarily blocked
oh my god they want the garage to
themselves oh my god
[Music]
no
if they say it's going to be blocked
it says it may be
did they do that i'm looking at it right
now so whack
uh they didn't block the content court
although
i don't think they're podcasted about
anything i claimed yeah i don't think
there was a problem with that but
i am man the barricades
it's still showing warning right now ass
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] losers yeah
yeah
maybe you can hit up your new bff kyle
and see if you can do anything about it
no he's not my bff anymore he's a piece
of [ __ ] oh that was [ __ ] domest
i love his [ __ ] trigger this idiot
face
[Music]
stupid-ass dumbass looking face guard
shut that car up your ass piece of [ __ ]
i take it back car's not a thing anymore
the car is gone
ah that's so annoying
it went away
yeah i mean it it just flashes it
temporarily
but we've been watching that thing for
like an hour and it only now just gave
me that warning so kinda weird
oh then maybe it was the music on the
tick tock
oh maybe
you think so
i think it's too delayed they they det
all right well we'll find out we'll find
out soon all right guys uh we'll see you
on wednesday for the bonanza
until then be good stay good
god bless keep your head down
suck on
on a gar
rip a dart suck a gar
put on tracking on your significant
other
[Music]
them every 10 minutes
[Music]
and die alone not you guys that you guys
will die with surrounded by friends and
family and loved ones yep
a beautiful peaceful death i wish a
beautiful peaceful death to all of you
of old age
yeah
all right guys see you wednesday
[Music]
give a shout out to my family ethan a b
cam dan
gila ian laina olivia sam zack
[Music]